[Music]
what's up guys andre here and today i'd
like to show you how you can use graphql
with laravel and vue
i feel like there isn't too much
information out there when it comes to
using graphql with larabel and vue
so i figured i'd make a few videos about
it and share my findings along the way
so if you're not familiar with graphql
it is an open source data query and
manipulation language for apis
it's been growing in popularity over the
last few years and is said to be the
replacement for rest apis i personally
think it's great and addresses the
issues with rest apis
so in this first video we'll take a look
at some examples of graphql just so you
can get more familiar with it and see
its advantages over rest
we'll take a look at some of the
packages we'll be using for laravel and
in view
so for laravel we'll be making use of
this lighthouse php package
and for view we'll be using view apollo
so this is the part where i usually show
you the finished product so you can see
what we'll be building in the next few
videos
but i'm not done it yet as i'm just
sharing my process along the way i am
done the design part so i'll show you
that and just talk you through what it's
supposed to
do so a very simple app as we're just
trying to learn graphql
it's a book recommendation site built
with graphql and all these technologies
we just talked about
so basically you can just perform crud
operations on books
and we have one basic relationship
where
a category has many books and a book
belongs to one category
and we'll also have
an option to add a book update a book
and delete the book so we'll click on
this it should go to this other screen
and here we can view the link for it if
you want to purchase it edit and delete
so there's no concept of users in this
app
because that kind of just adds
complexity obviously you need users for
most web apps but
i just wanted to get you to understand
the basics of graphql so we'll be
leaving users out of this
demo
so yeah i just want to give props to
where i got this idea from so if you go
to ihbooks.com
i saw this on product hunt a few weeks
ago
and it is basically where i got the idea
from
uh even the design i basically just
ripped
and even the book covers but i figured
it'd be a good app to build so we can
learn how to use graphql so yeah props
to the person who built this site it's
also a great site with many books i've
actually read so check it out if you're
interested in
some book recommendations
okay so i want to start with a quick
overview of some of the problems that
graphql solves over rest and for that
i'm going to be looking at the github
api because github has a traditional
rest api and also has a graphql api
so if you go to this url
you'll have access to the graphql api if
you click on explorer
and you do sign in with github
and here's where we can play around with
graphql and i also have my rest client
open
and we'll play around with the rest api
here
okay so here's one of the end points for
the github rest api and it's just
information about myself so if you go
here
here's some information about myself
so with rest it's all or nothing if you
only need one or two of these fields
you can't do that with rest because
you'll have to return everything when
you make the call to the api
i have seen some apis where you can do
something like fields equals and you
just specify the fields here that you
want returned
but there is no common specification
across all apis
and if you're going to look at a new api
they might have that and they might not
so with graphql
you can specify exactly what you want
returned so
let me just erase these comments
and right here
it's going to erase these
and
you can specify whatever you want return
so if i want my
login is the username and name is my
name
and there you go we get exactly what we
want and none of the extra stuff we
don't need
so this is a graphql query
which will be doing all of our work on
graphql in and if you notice
the query structure
is the same as the result that comes
back except the result has actual data
and i think that's a more intuitive way
than hitting multiple endpoints
and requesting data that way
so that's another thing with uh graphql
there's only one endpoint
usually it's a post request to slash
graphql
but you can change that if you like but
in general that's the end point with
rest there's multiple
endpoints and
sometimes there can be confusion over
which endpoint it should be
when you're making a new api what's
restful what's not restful
with graphql there's no arguments
because it's just one endpoint and this
expressive query language here
okay so another problem with rest is
sometimes the information you need is
not in this endpoint but another
endpoint so say for example i was making
an app that had to get the github info
uh so i'd hit this endpoint because i
need information about myself
but then i want to show my followers
and there is an endpoint here for
followers so right here
if i hit this
you'll see my followers here
so that means we have to make two ajax
requests
which is not exactly ideal
i mean it's not the end of the world but
you can see that that can start to add
up
if you need information across different
endpoints
in graphql since we have access to this
expressive query language we can just
specify that we want to show followers
in this one request
so
again there's also this nice
intellisense here
so followers and you can specify
parameters here
i just want the last 10
and don't worry too much about edges and
nodes which has to do with pagination i
believe
and i want the information for my last
followers i want also their login and
their name
if i hit that
there we go we have all the information
requested here in this nice format and
we can
display this as necessary in our front
end of our application
so yeah just a high level overview of
some of the advantages of graphql over
traditional rest
and now we can take a look at some of
the specific implementations and we'll
start with
laravel okay so like i said earlier
we'll be making use of this lighthouse
package which is a graphql server for
laravel
it's an excellent package
which has excellent documentation and
works really nicely
so if we go into the docs
and if you go into tutorial
there is a tutorial here
which shows you how to
get graphql up and running
with a typical blog
so
there's also a github repo
which we'll just make use of here
instead of building it from scratch
so let me just clone this real quick
so let me just go here get clone
and let's open that up
house tutorial
oops lighthouse
tutorial
and then open that in vs code
so you can go through the tutorial if
you want from scratch but let me just
show you
the essentials here so like i said it is
an implementation of a blog
so it's important to know the models we
have here so we have users
posts and comments and it's also
important to know the relationships
between them so users
has many posts
and a post belongs to a user
also a post has many comments
and
a
comment belongs to a post
so let's go ahead and add some data in
here and play around with graphql
so there is no environment file so let
me just quickly copy one
and let me just change my database
so i think i have one called lighthouse
tutorial setup already
and root
route
and i think just factory setup here
yeah so this factory is for each of the
models here
and in post factory
so yeah when i did this this should
actually be a sentence not a title
and is there cedars here
no there's no cedar so let's just
see if we can migrate first
oh sorry i have to composer install
all right that's page b artisan migrate
okay so let's quickly whip up some
seed data here using factories
so i'm going to start with users
app user
and let's make 10
create and let's make
say 20 posts
and let's make 20 comments
oops
so i just made another 20 users i meant
to make
more posts
sorry post
and let's make 20 comments
okay don't know why that first time
didn't work let's see if all our data
is in here so i think this is the right
database
so let's check our users
a whole bunch of users
posts a bunch of posts
and a whole bunch of comments okay so
now we have data
so let's go ahead and play with graphql
so back into the docs
so if you go to installation if you want
that
graphical
tool that i was showing you when i was
playing with the github api
you have to install this package and
you don't have to
but if you want that tool in the browser
then you have to install it
there are also desktop
applications which i prefer but let me
just show you this one first and then
i'll show you the desktop versions that
i prefer
so let's install that
and if we go into chrome
let's see if that works so it's
lighthousetutorial.test
and i believe it's slash graphql
or it could be graphql playground
let's see
okay so it's graphql dash playground
to access the tool
so there you go
just make that bigger
so now we can play around with graphql
and you can see that
there's already errors here because i
don't think there is a query specified
for user
so yeah let's take a look at
the schema here which is where you're
going to be spending most of your time
so it's under
things under routes
graphql schema.graphql
so in here you have to specify all your
types
also the relationships so this is
exactly like it's specified in
the database the user
and all the types the exclamation mark
means it's required and here is the
relationship so user has many posts
and is using a directive here which this
package makes a lot of use of directives
so same for the post we specify the
relationship the other way
or not the other way
the relationship oh here's the other way
between users and posts but here's
relationship between posts and comments
and the same here
and here is where the
queries live so if you want to make a
new query we have to define it in here
again there's heavy use of directives
which you should learn it looks weird at
first but it's actually really powerful
and
allows you to write
less code
but if you don't like directives then
you can just use custom resolvers and
just
query eloquent the fashioned way
which i will show you as well
so yeah back into
here
so this is a rex red squiggly because
there is no query for user
there's only posts and
posts
so if i change this to post then this
should return
there is no name for post it's a title
if you want auto complete
i think you can press control and
control space but that is bound to
alfred for me
but shift space works for me and you can
bring up the autocomplete
and you can hit this play button or you
can press command enter
and there you go it brings back that one
post that we asked for with id of one
again you can do everything
that you like in here
specify more fields
if you want the content
there you go
so
[Music]
let's look at the post for a second
we can also get the user it belongs to
and get those back so user
and just specify what you want returned
so we want the username
and we want the user email
and this is the user that created this
post
and also if you want to get the comments
for this post
there should be comments i think
comments
and we can just specify what we want so
i think the replies
what is it in comments
uh could be empty let's see
let's try putting the id in here which
id is this
oh you know why this post doesn't have
any comments so that's why it's
returning an empty array
so let's i think maybe
post of 20 maybe
okay so 50 has comments and there you
see it there cool
so let's quickly make a query for users
and let's just take what we already have
here
and let's just change it for users
so
this will just return all the users so
this is the query
this is the return type
so graphql is typed
that's what allows you to have that nice
autocomplete and the nice intellisense
which is great
so again this is a directive
and
there are a lot of directives for this
package which you should
get to know
right here
this is for the one user
we want to pass in an integer that's
required
and we want to make sure
we
we return just one user
here this is an array of users so it can
be
one or more this is just one
so we're going to find the user with an
id of whatever is passed in here
same thing with the post but for users
and now this should work in our schema
so
let me just
write another one here
so query
user id
of one
and let's just grab the name i believe
so we have to refresh it first someone
knows about it
okay and now we should get the
autocomplete
sorry this should be
a user
array not a user's array
refresh
and the error is gone and there you go
so so far we've just been looking at
query operations which are just read
operations
but there's also a mutation type which
has to do with any writing of data
so an update a delete or a create
so let's quickly go over that it's going
to paste in some code
again when we build out the real app
we'll start from scratch this is just a
demo so you have an understanding of how
it works with laravel and this package
so we specify a mutation
and
let me just fix this okay so these are
the parameters
it takes in a name
which is a string and it's required
and here are some validation rules again
this package makes heavy use of
directives which does look weird at
first but
you'll get used to it and if you don't
like it again you can use custom
resolvers
which i'll show you in a second so email
again
is required
and a password which it will hash using
bcrypt
and then it will return a user it will
return that created user
so let's try this out
so let me just comment this out
and instead of query it's going to be a
mutation
so let's do that mutation
the autocomplete is really really nice
really helps even if you don't know
graphql if you just play around
it will help you so create user
after refresh
so there you go create user
and it's going to give the parameters
that we need
name
andre
what's next email
andre at andre.com
password
is password
and then it should specify what we want
back
we just want the say the id
and the
name and if we do that
there we go id of 91
go into our database
if i refresh
and go over here
sorry it should be users
so
there we go i think i saw it
yeah right there
cool
so yeah let me show you
custom resolvers if you don't want to
use directives or if you can't do
something with just directives and you
need something more powerful or need
complete control
then you can just use custom directive
so i'll show you in
here
so let's just name it
latest post
this again this can be anything it could
be a really complex query which you just
want to use eloquent with
and you just have to specify the name
and the return
type and in this case it's going to
return a post just one
and then let's go to the docs
and i think there's a guide for
types
no it's not types fields i think there
we go custom resolvers
um so here's the example i'm about to do
but you can just make use of this
artisan command
so whatever you name the custom resolver
just make sure you make a class with a
capital l in this case
so i'm going to paste that in phpr is in
lighthouse it's a query you can do
custom resolvers for mutations as well
so latest post
let's go to that
latest post
and you can also have
parameters here and then you can access
the parameter from within the
class
but in our case we don't have a
parameter so in here
if we did have a parameter we'll just
specify it like like this
so we just get it
arcs and then if the name of the
parameter was that you can just do that
but we don't have one so
and in here you can do whatever you like
and you just have to make sure that you
return whatever you said you would
return here so in our case we have to
return a post so just one post
so i'm just gonna do return
post
all
and this is called last
again you can do
complex query or whatever you like in
here just make sure you return the right
thing
and that's it
so if we go back in here
um let me just comment this out
and let me just refresh actually
let's take this out
and i think i named it
latest post
yeah so just lay this post
so that should return the post and
just grab the title
up post not found
make sure to import it
so just import it here
okay
let's try again
there you go there's the latest post but
now we're using a custom resolver
if you need that
extra power
so yeah that's the gist of it uh you'll
be doing most of your work in this
schema graphql you can also split this
up if you like into multiple files if
this starts to get bigger
and
yeah so that's basically it for laravel
oh yeah so i personally like to
have this tool as a desktop app
and there are desktop apps for both
graphical and
graphql playground so this one's
graphical playground
and the other one that we used when we
were doing the github api is called
graphical so just search for them
graphical
[Music]
desktop
and you can download them
i believe they're electron apps and
graphql playground
desktop
you can search for them i have both of
them installed already um so let me just
show you quickly
so let me show you graphical first
so just paste
this url in
and you can do the same thing
so let me just grab this
paste that in and try it
and it works cool the other one's called
graphql playground
and let me just grab the
url again
it's a url
and
for some reason it knows i guess it took
the information from here
and there you go it works i personally
like this
um this is more like your
text editor so you can do things like
command d
you can move it up and down
you can have multiple cursors
so i prefer this over graphical but you
can use whatever you like i prefer it
again as a desktop app
because
you know we tend to have a million
things running in our tabs
so just organization purposes i like to
use the desktop app
okay so let's take a look at how to use
graphql on the front end so up to now
we've just been playing around on the
back end and using these tools uh to to
interact with graphql so how do we
consume it from the front end
we need to use a graphql client and in
this case we're going to use view apollo
which is very nice and easy to use
so let's go ahead and get started and
let's install it so i already have a
view cli 3
application scaffold it out
and i literally did not do anything to
it i just did view create and that's it
and it's running right here
so
the installation is very straightforward
if you're using vcl3 you can also do it
the manual way but
this way is much quicker and easier so
i'm just going to do view add apollo
oops let me go into it first
and view add apollo
so it's asking if you want example code
i'm going to say no
we don't need a server because we
already have one
okay so there are the files that have
changed and it's installed
so let's go ahead and go into
actually no this is there well let's go
into our view app
and i'm just going to play around here
in hello world
so let me just close the stuff
so what i want is i want to make a
data property down here
and i want this populated with
stuff from the back end so
return say users let's make it an empty
array
and let's also make one for
just user
let's make that null
okay
so how do we get
the information from our backend graphql
into here
so
obviously we'd make use of these queries
so let me just bring one up
so let's just get something very basic
users and let's grab
their name
and their email
and not sure why this isn't working let
me refresh
okay there we go
so we just want this information
in our front end
so if we go into the docs
for queries
so obviously we'd have to make use of
this query somehow so the way to do that
is to
import this graphql gql thing so let me
import that up here
and
we have this new apollo property
and so let's put that
right underneath here
and here is where you would specify
so we want to populate users
with this query so we'd use gql and then
we use template strings
to put the query in there so in our case
um we just want this
so you can put query but you don't have
to
so i'm going to leave it out for now
just so it's a bit shorter
users
so it's basically this basically that
this query right here so we just want
name and email
name and email
and
yeah let's give that a try
what is this complaining about
i'm sorry this should be a method
okay so
let's see if this works
so
this should populate when the component
loads so let's see if that works
i'm going to open this
see if you have any errors first
and check review
devtools let's go into our hello world
app
and let's check our
users it's undefined so it's not working
so yeah obviously it's not working
because we didn't specify the endpoint
so if you go into this file view
apollo.js within the source directory
we can specify the endpoint here
so it's trying to hit this endpoint
obviously that's not the correct
endpoint
so
it's
what is it again it's
lighthousetutorial.test
slash graphql
okay so that should do it
save that
and see if this works
so there it is loading
and as you can see we're getting course
errors here so let's quickly fix that
so we have to install
laravel cores on the back end
and specify a middleware for the
lighthouse package
let me just install this real quick
in the back end
and while that's going usually you would
install the
the uh
the package using middleware here in app
http kernel
but in our case we want to put it in the
config of lighthouse
so let's go ahead and do that let's go
back to our back end
and i believe it's in config
lighthouse
there it is
and i think there's a section for
middleware here
yeah so it goes right here under this
route config
sorry
uh
let me just
uncomment this
and then we can add
that package right here
cool
and now this should be done obviously
okay
and this should work now on the front
end
okay no more course errors
let's check our view config
view devtools i mean and there you go 91
users
so
this corresponds to
our database there should be 91 users in
here
and there is cool
and you will display this as you please
in your front end i'm not going to do
that
okay so let me quickly do a mutation and
then
i think that should give you a good idea
of how graphql works in our back end and
our front end
so let me just make a button here
quickly in the hello world component
up here
just put it
right here
button sorry
um
say at click equals
handle click
say mutation test
mutation
and let's make a methods for handle
click
so i'm going to put it right after
apollo
methods
handle
click
so if you look at the docs there's a
section here for mutations
right here
so i'm just going to copy and paste this
video getting quite long
so you would just make use of this
apollo mutate and then put in the
graphql
for the mutation
so let's go ahead and do that real quick
just gonna paste this in
so this apollo mutate
and the mutation i'm doing is this
so i'm creating a user
and i'm just hard coding some data in
here
and
this corresponds to
the create user
mutation that we have here
and that should work
so let me just
do that and then let's see if this works
okay
so that should have reloaded
i'm missing a comma somewhere
i think i'm missing a closing bracket
here
okay let's try it again
yeah i was missing another
closing brace there
okay so there it is
so let's test this mutation
uh there's going to be no feedback
let's just see if that added like it did
so let's just refresh this
and there you go
cool
i like to start building out this book
recommendation site in graphql
if you haven't seen the last video we
took a look at using graphql with both
laravel and vue and the tools available
to us
in this video i'd like to start building
out this app
and we're going to start with the back
end using laravel
okay so let's go ahead and make a new
laravel app
so i'm going to do laravel new let's
call it books ql
laravel and then the front end will be
called booksql view
alright let's open that up
and let's open it up in code
so let me just set up my database
i already have a database
made so it's called booksql
laravel
and it's root
root
okay so
we need to start by making our models
and our migrations
so
again if you look at the design we only
have two models and one relationship
between them we have categories and we
have books and the relationship is a
category has many books
and a book belongs to one category
so realistically you probably want to
have
a book to belong to many categories
but
i'm just trying to make this as simple
as possible so we're just going to have
the
belongs to one category relationship
so let's make our models let's start
with the category
make
model
category and
dash a will create a migration and a
controller which we don't need but let's
create it anyways in the factory
let's do the same for
the book
so let's open that up and let's set the
relationships so start with category
and i'm gonna
set the guarded to an empty array just
because i'm gonna
make a cedar
later on
and let's set the relationship so a
category has many books
so
[Music]
i guess my snippets don't work anymore
okay
books
and let's do
return
this
has many
book class
okay
and let's do the same for
the
book
so i'm going to do guarded as well
then do
a
this
belongs
to category
class
okay
now let's set up the migrations and on
all the fields on the book so create
books table
and i am just going to paste this in
to save some time
and then i will go through each of the
fields
so
the title obviously the author
so the image is going to be a string
and it can be empty
the description is just a longer form
text the link is a string
this featured flag is because in the
design i have a featured
category here
uh maybe i'll design a different two
maybe i'll have a hero
that displays some featured books
anyways that's the idea i'm not sure if
we're going to use that
but there is a featured boolean
column there
so this is the relationship with
category
so a book belongs to a category so we
need a category id
and that is a foreign key on the
categories table
and that's it
so let's do the same for
create categories table
and this only has one field
it's just
the name of the category
okay
so let's see if we can migrate this
okay so that works
so
now i want to make a seeder just so i
have realistic data
and the data i have in my seeder are all
of these books here i have in the design
maybe i'll add more later on but there
is about this many
and i didn't make it very
very realistic in terms of the
categories i just dumped
like the first six in the first category
and the next six the next category and
the next three in the next category
just so how every category has at least
a few books
so let's make a cedar
start with the categories so php artisan
make
seed
categories
table cedar
oops why is there a dash there
okay and let's also do one for books
and it's going to
our
seeds
database tables heater and it's
just to
[Music]
start with the categories
and let's do the books after that
and obviously i'm not going to make you
watch me do this i'm just going to paste
in
what i have here in my other project
so this is the books tables heater it's
a whole bunch of books
and i'm going to paste in the category
staples theater
and this is just a few categories
okay so i have these categories and
all of these books over here
cool so now let's try to
migrate fresh
where's migrate fresh and it's also seed
dash dash seed
and that looks good let's see if we have
data
some books
cool a bunch of books and
some categories here cool
okay so you see i also have
the cover images here
so i'm just going to put these in
so this is the project i already did
and i already have
the cover images here
so i'm going to put these in
the public folder
we're not going to use it in this video
but
we're going to need it eventually when
we make use of the cover images
so i'm just going to put it in an image
folder
and paste them in
i guess i can't paste can i paste
okay so they're all in here now cool
okay now we can start using the
lighthouse package so let's go ahead and
install that
installation composer require
let's do that
okay next is
this
publishes the default
schema.graphql file which we can make
use of and then we can modify it later
on
so let's do that
okay
and i'm not going to use this dev tools
i'm just going to use the one on my
desktop so
it's graphql playground
and
we'll use that when we need to use it
and i also want the config
where's that
i have to publish the config as well
okay so that
okay
and that is published cool
okay so now back to our code
and the first thing we need to do is
let's go into our schema graphql so
that's in
routes
graphql schema
and you can see we have some boilerplate
here which we can
use
will not use we'll model our models
after it
so first thing i want to do is define
our types
so
we'll like i said we're not going to
have users in this app
just to keep things simple
so
it's definer types we'll leave it in
there for now
we'll leave the user in there for now so
the first thing we have is a book
and this is just the field we defined in
the migration so
create
book
so all of this stuff but in graphql
format
so we have
id and this is of type id
and id is a field type in graphql
and it's required
title is a string it's required
author
string required
image
string
not required
link
string
not required
description
string
not required featured
boolean
not required
and
a book
belongs to a category
so we have to specify the relationship
here
and it is a category and we'll define
that right after this
and it is it belongs to relationship
okay
so that is our book type and then the
next type is category
and let's do the same thing id is id
required name
string required
and it's set up the relationship
books
is an array of books that's what it
returns
and the relationship is has many
and that is it for our types so now
let's start defining the queries and the
mutations
so
um let's get our design to see how the
app's supposed to work
so the default view
although this doesn't represent that i
just want to show all the books
um
no pagination because that just
i mean in a real app you would have
pagination but
again it's trying to make this as simple
as possible
you can see that
the
example here uses paginate and we won't
be using paginate anyway so we just want
all the books so that's the most basic
query we can do
so let's just
do books
and that's going to return a book array
and that's required
actually it's not required because it
can be null
and we're just going to use the all
directive and that will return all books
so let's go ahead and try this out in
our graphql playground so it's books ql
dash laravel
booksql
test graphql
okay
and
what is it again it's books so query
make this bigger
that big enough one more
so query
um
books
and
let's return the
title
there you go
book was not found
okay so
in the config so if we go to the
lighthouse config
it's in config lighthouse
there is an option here that says where
the models are supposed to be not sure
why they defaulted to app models because
the default functionality for laravel is
it just goes into the
app folder
so if we do that that should fix that
error
let's try again
refresh it first
let's try again
there we go
and we can do whatever we like here id
what else
author
cool
so what else do we need
for our app to work
we also need to be able to get the
details for one book
so for this view we need to make another
request when we
click on one and it goes here
so let's do that
and let's go to
and we'll just copy
this
and we'll just change it so
this will be book
just one book
and the parameter is the book id
um later on maybe we can change this to
a slug
that would be more url friendly and more
seo friendly
and it's going to return one book
and we want to find
that book based on the ideas passed in
so
you can specify the model but i don't
think we have to
and let's go ahead and try that
so
let me just
query
book
oh let me refresh
book
there we go
we need an id
fashion one
and we can do the same thing id title
author
cool
and if you want the category for this
book since there's a relationship we can
already we can do that as well
so let's go category
and then what's the types here
we can just get the name
so there you go
this book by this author is in this
category
okay so let's go ahead and
define the endpoints for categories as
well
so let's do that
so it's basically just this
but for categories so let's be
categories
this will be an array of categories
and all this will be a category
and we'll take an id as well
and this will be a category
okay let's try that out
these this should work as well
but for a category let me refresh real
quick
and this should be a category
and obviously a category doesn't have
this
has a name
cool
and we can also do
categories
and
name
cool so that's all the categories
so back to our app
we want to be able to click the category
and just have it filtered by those books
so that's really built in since we have
that relationship defined
so say for example we wanted everything
in
marketing category
so marketing is
id1 i think
okay it is
so let's get the category first
so category
id
one
and
because we have that relationship
defined right here in the type
the category i mean
then we can get the books for this
category and that's exactly what we need
in our app
so let's just do
books
and we can specify the fields we want so
in our case
what do we want
we're going to want the name the author
the cover
or i can name the image
and the id because we're going to click
on that and
we want to go to a different route okay
so id
uh title
author
and this thing i call the image
so there you go we have all this
information that we need which we can
use on our front end when we start
working on our front end
what else
so like i said we also have this
featured
category which is not really a category
it's just an extra field on the
model
so how do we filter by just
books that are featured
so let's add one more here to books
let's call it books
by featured
so like i said in the first video if you
don't like directives you can just use
custom resolvers
but
if you want to make use of directives
you can do it like this
so featured
is a boolean as required
and we want to use the eq directive
and this is going to return
an array of books
and it can be empty so let's not put the
exclamation mark and let's grab all
so all the books that are
featured based on this parameter coming
in
so right now
another feature
so this should return an empty array of
books so let's see if that happens
uh what did i name it books by featured
let me refresh this
books by featured
and then let's grab the title
it should be empty
oh sorry i need the
featured is true
so it should be empty because none of
them are featured
cool
and if i say false this should be
all of the books
okay
so if i add one if i manually
set one to featured or a few of them
let's go to books
let's say
this one this one
this one
this one and this one
and save that
let's go back here
and this should now have a few of them
cool
and again i did this in the last video
and i just mentioned it but
if you have
some complex query that directives can't
handle or if you just don't like
directives you can use custom resolvers
so let's say
some complex
query
search
is the
parameter
and it's a string
and it returns an array of books
and we can just use the command line
uh forgot what's called it's called
lighthouse query i think yep
so php artisan light house query
and name it some complex
query so it has to be the same name as
this
and obviously you don't use directives
here because the class will handle that
okay
so that
goes into i think app
http graphql some complex query
so here is where the logic goes
so you can do whatever you like in here
some complex
query
but since i
named the premise parameter search let's
do a basic search here you can do this
with directives as well but let's just
do this return
book
where
say app book
author so this is going to do a search
for the author
like
and
let's do this
so
i just want to search on the argument
that's passed in so i'm going to do some
wild cards here
and to pass into the argument here's to
args
and the name of the argument so we named
it search in our graphql schema so
we can use that
and just add another percent here so it
does a wild card search
and
just make sure to get it
and this should be a search now
so let's try it
refresh
and i'm going to do
um
some complex query which is actually a
search
search by
gary i have two books in there by gary
vee
and let's grab the title
and
obviously the author is the same so
title
and author
and let's try
that
app book not found
slash app slash book
refresh
try again
there we go so there's that
custom
some complex query which is actually
just a search
but we're using custom resolvers
okay so now let's do some mutations uh
we obviously want to be able to create
update and delete our models
so let's do that
so back to our schema
right
here so there's already an example
for creating updating and deleting users
and we can make use of this for our
models
so let's start with
creating i'm going to copy this
and let's start with categories
so let's rename this to create category
and we only need a name for category so
here is this
so it's going to be a string
it's going to be required
and i also want it to be unique
so let's say unique when you choose
variables rule rules
unique on categories table
and unique on the name column
so that should do the trick
make sure to change this
we can take the small note
it should be create it should be
category
and let's do the same for update and
delete
and then we can test it out after
split space here
so update category
so it's required
the id is required and it's just a name
and it is the same rules as this
and we don't need this
this is a category
and the same for delete
required category
delete don't need the model
okay so let's start let's try creating
one updating one and then deleting one
and then we'll do the same for books
actually it's the same process for books
it's just more fields i'll do that
behind the scenes and then i'll show it
to you guys working
so let's try
let me just put it here in the middle so
it's easier to see
so it is let me just delete this it's a
mutation
we're going to do create category
let me refresh
create category
and
create a name
say new category
and then we just want
the id
and
just to say the name
okay so that created a new one called
new category
so if we check the database
there it is right there
cool
and what's next update category
so let's change that
to update
and the parameter is the id so it's
seven i think it's the id
yep seven so let's say seven
and we also need
the name we wanna change it to
so new category
update
and
let's change see if that works
and it did let's check the database
there we go cool
and let's delete the category
so delete
it just needs the id i think
cool
and we can return that
so
if you read the error message it says
the id should be
non-null so the idea should be none no
cool
let's try it again refresh
try again
there we go seven should be gone now
there we go awesome
so yeah i'm gonna do the books behind
the scenes it's basically the same
things just more fields
and then i'll show it to you guys when
i'm done
okay so i added mutations for creating
updating and deleting books
so let me just show you that it works
so
[Music]
let's try this one first create book
a new book
and i'm just hard coding the category in
here
and returning the id and title
okay so that's id26
see if that is in the database
so there it is right there cool
so let's update it
so the next one is update
so let's change it to 26.
a new book changed some author changed
okay
let's run that
okay
check the database
there you go cool
and let's delete the book
so mutation delete book
26
and that should delete it
and it's gone cool
so yeah i think that's all the
operations we need on the back end
um we might tweak things while we work
on the front end and realize we missed
something but i think that is all
we have all the crud operations for both
our models
and we tested both and everything looks
like it's working
i like to start the front end of our
graphql app using view and view apollo
in the last video we built out our
graphql backend in laravel and in this
video i'd like to start on the front end
okay so let's go ahead and make a new
view app using the view cli so i'm going
to do view create
books ql
view
and let me make sure to add view router
because we're going to be making use of
that we need a router and let me just
add view x we probably won't need ux but
let me just add it anyways
okay so that's done let me go into it
and it's
npm run
serve
okay so here it is
i'll style everything later on in
another video using tailwind css
for now i just want to dump everything
on the page
and get everything wired up and working
with our back end so it's going to look
ugly for this video and then we'll make
it look pretty in the next video okay so
let me show you what i have in mind as
to how we're going to approach this
first i want to dump all the categories
on the page
so we'll make use of that categories
i mean the categories query in our
graphql
and then i want to dump out all the
books
just all the books for now
and then we can focus on getting
just the books in a specific category
and then we'll get routing working where
we click on one of the books and it goes
to this page
and then after that i want to get
the
mutations working so editing deleting
and adding a book is here and i think
i'll add a new route for that too
so yeah a lot of work to be done let's
see if we can fit it in one video it's
going to be really long but if i can get
it within like an hour or so i'll leave
it at one video
okay so
i need to add laravel cores first
on the back end i did that in the first
video so let me just quickly do it here
um
so yeah if i was running both on
localhost then it shouldn't i shouldn't
need to do this but since i'm using
laravel valet and i'm running on
a test domain
then we need cores so let me just
install this
real quick
and i need to install it on the
booksql laravel site
okay
and let me just grab this and put it in
the lighthouse config
so i think i have it running here in the
background
there it is
so i think it's lighthouse config
should be
right here so middleware
we'll just put
that in here
and we should be good to go
okay so
back to our
yeah so i just want to dump the
categories so let's go to our front end
and i'm going to put it in
it's going to dump everything in this
home
view
and maybe in another video we'll
refactor our code into nice reusable
components
so let me just get rid of these two
and get rid of this
and this
okay
so
let me go into the docs we have to
install it
i should do this after i installed the
view app so just to view add apollo
and that should do it
okay that's done let me just add the
endpoint in our view apollo.js right
here
it's going to be
booksql
laravel dot slash graphql
okay
and let's go ahead and finally
dump the categories
so
if we go to queries we can
import this gql
thing we need to perform queries
in our front end so let's do that
so i'm going to import gql here
and then
make a query in here
so i'll put it right here
cool
and the query we need is just grab all
categories so let me go into graphql
playground
and do it in here first
so that would be
um
let's get rid of this
categories
and we're gonna want
the id and the name
okay so that is the query we need so
let's go back into our code
and let's do
just categories id name so
categories
id name
and let's make a data state property
called
categories
uh i'm not sure if i
actually need one or if i can just
put it in the apollo property like that
we'll just make one
we're actually not going to do it this
way i'm going to show you how to do it
using components in a second
but just as a starting point
so categories
and let's make it an empty array
okay
oops should be returned
return object
okay
so let's see if this works
back to our
app here let's see
and it looks like i'm still getting
coors errors
okay oh okay it's gone now
so that should work now let's see
let's go into the
home component
and
there are the categories cool so it does
work
awesome
okay so
like i said
i want to
make use of
components so apollo components apollo
query
uh you can still do it this way if you
would like
but doing it this way
just allows you to clean up some of your
javascript and
in some in this instances you don't even
need the javascript and you just
use this apollo query which uses a scope
slot
to grab all the information you need
so yeah let me just grab this
and let me show you what i mean
so i'm going to paste this in
up here
and here you would
you're going to separate your
actual graphql query
into a file and that is
a good way to keep your code more
organized in my opinion so i'm going to
make a new folder here
called
graphql
and i'm going to make two new folders
one for queries
and one for mutations
and for this one specifically
i'm gonna have one called
this is categories so categories
dot gql
and all this is gonna have is our query
here so let me just grab this
paste this in here
and save that and let's continue working
on this so this would be graphql slash
queries
slash categories graphql
and like i said this is using scope
slots and if you're not familiar with
scope plots don't worry
too much about it
this just grabs the data and it
destructures it here
which allows us to use it in our
template
so let's erase these comments
and
there's a conditional here and it just
shows loading you can put a spinner in
there if you like
if it's not loaded yet but if it is we
can iterate through them and display
them so let's do that
so we are using a category
and we're going to get it from data dot
categories
and then we can just
output
the id
and
the name
and it's also put a key in here
and make a category.id
and
that should work hopefully let's see if
it works
so yeah when i was doing this i got this
error and it took me quite a while to
figure out how to fix it
and hopefully
what i did before i fixed it again and
the answer to that is just to delete
your node modules
and try again
i mean delete your node modules and npm
install again so i'm going to do that
so let's go ahead and do that
let me just stop this and do it in here
so
node modules should be in there so let's
do rm rf node
modules
[Music]
and let me npm install again
okay so it's done let me try running it
again and let's see if it works this
time
okay so it looks like it did work
there's some warnings there but let's
see if it worked
and there you go it did work it showed
it
and
it's displaying it correctly
so these warnings can get quite annoying
as you write more queries
so
there's a package that allows you to
have autocomplete for graphql in here
which is really nice
but i actually haven't had
a chance to look at that so what i'm
going to do is just add a
eslint
ignore file
and i'm just going to add star star
slash
star dot gql
to it
and
hopefully that removes the warnings
so let's try again
okay so it looks like it did cool
so back to our code if you look here
there should be
a brief period where there should be a
loading state and it's getting it from
here and it's displaying loading when
it's loading but if you look closely if
i refresh
there is no loading here
so you see nothing there
so i'm not sure if that's a bug but the
way i fixed it was to use another
property here
called is loading
and use that instead and if we do that
that works so if we save that
and if we refresh
there you see the loading
indicator
before the data is load from the back
end
okay
let me just make this a bit bigger for
you guys
okay so these should actually be links
so let's change that
so i'm not going to use a ul anymore
i'm just going to use a div
and for these i will use anchor tags
and let's just make them go to nowhere
and we add a period between the id and
the name
and let me just add a class here called
link margin
and let's put it here
in the style
sorry
style
link margin
let's make it margin right
well 24 pixels
see how that looks
doesn't seem to be auto reloading for
some reason
okay that's fine
okay now let's dump all the books so
very similar to this let's just dump all
the books
so i'm just going to grab this
duplicate it
and let's add a new query for books
so first let's
do it in here so it should be books
and
when we have id
title
author
and image i think
okay
so let's grab this
and put it into our books query
okay
and then
let's
put it in here the whole should the
whole thing should be a link as well but
we'll just put as a div
and
let me just remove this again we'll
style this in the next video if i get
through all this front-end stuff
and this should be
let's just dump the books
book sorry this should be book
data.books
key is book id
and let's just jump dump the book id
and the book title
just to see if it works
and yeah does seem to work cool
okay so now we want to be able to click
these and have
these books filter based on the category
that we clicked on
so first let's take a look at the query
that we need for that so that would be
a specific category
so let me just remove all this
so it'll be category
and then i need to pass it an id so just
grab the first one
and we can get the id in the title of
that category but what we want is
the books for it
sorry name of the category
and then books
and then we want
id
title
author
and
image
there we go
okay so let's copy this
and let's make a new query
let's call it
category singular
and let's paste that in
let me save that and back to our home
view
let's change what we have here to make
use of that new one just to see if it
works so instead of books
let's use category and right now
the category is just i mean the id is
just hard-coded we obviously want to
pass the id from here
into the query and we'll do that in a
second let's just see if this works
and yeah that's not going to work
because
the format of the data coming back is
different
so let me put that back and we make
another one here
just underneath all of this
uh let me comment that out for now
let's make another one and this one
leaves the category
and let's look at the structure coming
back
so
the structure is data.category.books
so let's go and do that
so book of data.
category
dot books
and
that should still work so we hard coded
category id 1 in there
so this is one so that's good
so it seems to work if we change it to
two
here
that should return everything in
category two
and that's cool
so now let's see how we can use
variables
so the id is not hard coded and it's
passed in
so in our category graphql
we can just accept variables like this
so we need an id it's of type id as
required
and we can just accept that in here
and now in our front end
back to home
we can
accept a variables prop like this
so variables
equals and we can just put it in line
here
so
id is
we'll hardly close it for now and then
we'll have a dynamic piece of state that
keeps track of that as we click a
category
so let's say
two or put it back to one actually
and this should
work
and there we go back to one change that
to two
cool
so yeah we need to keep track of the
selected category
so let's go ahead and do that
i'm going to put a new piece of state
here called selected category
and let's default that to one
that should still work
cool
but as we click on those links so
these links here we want to update that
selected category
so where's that link right here
so let's make a
click handler here
on click
sorry it's click
i am
going back between react and view so
okay so click is
let's make a method called select
category
let's pass in
the category category.id
and down in our method let's just update
that state
so let's make a new section here called
methods
select
category
and that will accept a category
and let's just do
this dot selected category
is the category that's passed in
so now
this should switch based on
what we click
so by default it's one
and that doesn't seem to work let's see
what's going on
select category is not a function
oops select category
try it again
let's refresh this
okay
and there we go
it's getting a new
passing in the variable and getting a
new set as we click on the category cool
okay so if you look at the design you'll
see that we have all the categories here
but we also have
these two extra
they're not categories but there's one
for featured and one for all categories
so these are separate queries from the
categories so let's see how we could
implement those
so first i want to add those two here so
let me just add those to the
template
so
just hard code them in here
outside of the for loop and let me just
add a prevent
here just so
because if you click on this it
it goes to the top of the page if you
have a hash in here so let me just add
that
so let's do that again
add
link
margin let's add one for
all
let's add one for
featured
and see how it looks
okay
so here we're passing in an id
and for these ones let me describe this
we don't need ids we need a whole whole
new query so here's what i'm going to do
let me add these
for this one
i'm going to pass in
all
and we'll do a check in that select
category method
and we'll check if it's either all
featured
and if it's not all are featured then
it's just going to be an id and then we
can just fetch it this way
but if it's all or featured we have to
use another
query here
so let me show you what i mean so let's
go back to that method select category
and we still have to do this we still
want to update it
but now we need different queries based
on the category
so if
the category coming in is
all
then i'm going to make a new piece of
state called query
and we're going to hold each query in a
variable
so let me show you what i mean
so let's make this new piece of state
first called query
and
we will default that to
a query called books query
which we already have and should return
all books
so let me fix that in a second let me
just finish this conditional here
so else if
category
is featured
then we need another query
called
let's call it books
featured
query and we'll add that in a second
else
this dot query equals category query
which we already have but we have to set
it to this variable
so i hope that makes sense
so let me just add these queries so i'm
going to add this one because we already
have it first
so let me just get rid of this i don't
need this anymore since
we are using apollo components
and
what can i get rid of there yeah we
don't need all of this
okay
and let me add
we can just import the queries here
so i'm going to import
category
query
from
graphql
queries
category
query
and i want to set that in our state
so i can do category query
and i can set up the category query or i
can just leave it
because it's the same name
so now we can replace
the query that we imported up here
right here
to just category query
and everything should still work
and it does not
sorry did i name it category.query
should be category
dot gql
sorry it should be gql
okay so yeah this is not gonna work
because i have to import this query as
well
so let's go ahead and do that
this one already exists we just have to
define a variable for it but books query
is
it's called books
and that just returns all books
and we can add that here as well
and we might as well import
this one up here that we're using
already categories query
and we'll use that
we'll just use that instead
so we'll call it
categories query
let's import that
so right here
categories query
and let's use that just put underneath
here
and we need one more
for the featured
query so if you click featured we want
to filter by that so i'm going to make
it here
books featured query
books
featured
and let's add that here books
featured
query
so yeah let's take a look at that
sorry i had to restart my computer i was
being really slow so i lost everything
here so let's just
test out that books by featured so books
by featured
i think it takes
a featured
let's say to true
and this will just return all the books
so id
title
author
image
okay
so let's grab this
let's
add a new query
books featured
gql let's paste that in
and let's add in the variables while
we're here so it should be
featured
boolean required
and featured is featured
okay
save that
save this i think
okay this is not going to work yet
it should
run but it's not going to work
okay
so wait i think these ones
okay so right now it is
will this work okay so this one doesn't
work
because
in our template
we only have
one apollo query and the structure of
the graphql coming back from the back
end is different for each
case we have here
so we're going to need a conditional in
the template here to check if it's
either all
featured
or
the default case or the else case is
going to be a category so
what is it right now
where's the data
so right now it's defaulting to
the selected category of one which is
what you see when you reload the page
so i want it to default to all to show
all the books so let's do that
let's change this to all
and then we're gonna have to change the
structure of our apollo query
actually i think i have it up here yeah
i do have it up here
so let me just use this and then we'll
add a conditional around this probably
not the cleanest way but
again
this is just a first
pass so this is going to be
what is this books query
sorry no this is going to be query
because this gets updated
as we click on it
as we click on these links up here
and we're changing it down here yeah
okay
and the default is this books query
okay so now we have to add the
conditionals
so let me add a div here
do the
if
selected category
is all
then we can just do this
let me just indent that
and then we can do a
so this case would be
uh this should this is going to be the
else case and i'll have an else
else if case as well
for the feature
let me just handle this one
so this will be the
v else
and
yeah this should work
but
the uh
feature this one should not work but all
and the categories should work
okay so right now it's showing all of
them cool
if i click on one of these it should
work as well
and it does cool
two three awesome okay
so this one's not gonna work
let's just add that case in
so we need
grab this
it's going to be else if
category is featured
and this is fine
all right like i said there's a lot of
repeated code here but
i'm okay with this for now
so for this it's going to be book of
data dot
if you look at the query it's books by
featured
by featured
and this remains the same
and i think this should work now
oh you get all them featured i think i
have some features in there
books by featured of undefined
oh yes i need variables for this
so in this case we can just hardcode
true
because
we don't want the case for its when it's
false
featured
true
let's try it again
so all
there we go so these are the featured
ones
and
these are the
categories so i get an error here but
still seems to work i'm not sure what
that error is but
yeah this seems to work cool
okay so next i want to work on routing
here
so i want to click on
one of these books and then i want to go
to this
dedicated book page so let's go ahead
and do that
so let me make a new view called let's
call it book
and let's just
just copy this
and just call it this is a
book page
okay
and let's set up the route for that so
if we go into router js
right here
let's make a new one we'll just
duplicate this
and we'll call it
books
and then the wild card is going to be
id
and we'll call it book
and book.view
okay so that should work
so
book slash one
okay
so let's
make a link here for these books
um let's do that
so back to our home view
let's just
add a link here
so now it has to be a link so change
this to
that
actually not a anchor
we're going to use a router link
and it's going to go to
these template strings here
slash books
slash
book dot id
and
we have to do this for
all of these cases here
so let me just
do it like this
didn't close it properly
router link
and the same for this case
router link
okay let's see if that works
it does
so
let me just wrap these in divs so
they're block level elements
and so they're on their own line
same with this
and this one too
and that did nothing
oh sorry i meant to wrap this
within a div
is that what i meant to do
i think so let's try
um
so yeah let's try wrapping this in a div
okay there we go
okay so no i didn't mean to do that i
just meant to leave this as a div and
have the router link
here
so let me just undo these changes
back up
okay so that should be back
to where it was before
and yeah i want the router link around
here
so it's going to be a router
link
let me just put this at the end
and it's going to be
i should just copy it
two equals
slash books slash
book id
okay so yeah that's what i want
so let's just make sure that works
cool
effects like it okay it goes there
and let me just make sure i put this on
these ones as well
okay
so now that we're here we might as well
add the image
and the author name in here
so i'm going to do that in here so let
me add
the author first
uh book author
okay
and let's add the image
so image
let's do that a bit so this would be
cover image
and let's find this
and i'm going to use a template string
here
and in the back end if you remember let
me show you the database
we have the image
just the name of the file
and what i should have done is just have
the full path in here so we can just
grab it from the back end and just spit
it out on the front end
so i'll probably make that change
behind the scenes but for now
i'm just gonna hard code the actual url
here
so it's books ql
image
slash
and then
book.image
so yeah again you should store the full
path on the back end but i'm not going
to do that here i just want to say it
working
okay so there it is and there's the rest
of them
cool
okay so i am going to
copy this
and do the same for these two
okay
so now there should be images for all of
these
okay featured
marketing
cool and all the categories awesome
cool okay
okay now
i would need the book information as i
click on this and here we want to make
another request to the back end to grab
the book information here and we have
the id in the url here
so let's go back to our book
component
and to get the id all you have to do is
this
uh route
params id i think this is a dollar sign
so let's see
okay there you go
and if i change this
cool
so yeah all we have to do is
just grab an apollo query here similar
to this
and just display the book information
so i'm going back here let me remove
this
let me just indent
okay so query is going to be
let's just go back to the require syntax
and it's going to be
graphql
queries
book dot gql
so i don't have that defined yet but
that's the one that just gets one book
and that goes here like that
and we also need variables
and the variable is just going to be
the route param
so it's going to be
id is route.params.id
and let's take a look at the playground
to see how to structure that query
so we just need a book
that's going to be
book
pressing the id
start code 1
and id title
author
and
we probably need all the information
here since we're on the book detail page
but we'll just return what we need here
book author
image
what else do we have here anyways let me
check the database
so yeah let's just return everything
here image description link
featured
description
link
featured
and we want the category
we're going to need this later on so
there's a category
yeah it's category
and we need let's grab the id and the
title
okay
sorry this is name
cool so yeah let's just grab this
and let's make a new
query for just book
let's paste that in
and let's add the variables or the
parameters that we need so
id is type id
required
and here instead of hard coding it
will put in the id oops
id
okay so that looks good
and down here
so
[Music]
we no longer need a v4 since it's just
one piece of information coming back so
it's just going to be
let's see is it data yes it's gonna be
data
dot book dot whatever so data.book.title
and
data.book.author and you can put in the
rest of the stuff we'll add this when we
style it
but let's put the image in here as well
so image
source is again i'm gonna hard code
the url but you should store this on the
back end as a full path
booksql variable
test
image
slash
data.book
okay
book cover
close this out
and let's see if this
works
so it does work awesome
yeah so it works for all of our books
here
and let's go back to the home page and
see if clicking it works
awesome
so yeah
i thought i could fit all of this into
an hour but this is already pretty long
so i'm going to stop it here
so we have all our
queries done which takes care of reading
the data but we still have to work on
the mutations
so if you look at our design
we can edit and delete a book from here
and we can also
add a book from here
and
there's also crowd operations for
categories but we'll just be focusing on
the books here
i like to continue working on the front
end of our graphql application and more
specifically i like to work on mutations
so in the last video we got most of our
queries working
so we have
the ability to display all books
featured books
and books in certain categories here
and we also have a routing so it goes to
a specific book and shows the details of
that
and now i'd like to work on
mutations
so if you look at our design
you'll see that there are links here for
editing and deleting this specific book
and there's also a link here for
adding a book so let's start with adding
a book and then we'll work on creating
and deleting i mean updating and
deleting after
so back into our home view
let's go all the way up here and let's
just put a link here
let's make it a router link
and we are going to make it go to
books
create
books that's great
so let me just put that in the router
so i am going to
duplicate this one
and i'm going to put it up here so it
takes precedence over this one
so books
create
our let me name it books
add
that kind of sounds better because
you're not creating a book you're adding
a book
so
let's name it add
book
and let's name it add book view
okay let's make a new component here
for adding a book
view
and let's just put something in here
form for adding a new book
goes here
okay
and let's see if this works
and i don't think i have my
app running i do have it running
so where is it
oh i forgot to put something in here
add a book
so there it is
okay
did i change this i think i forgot to
change it
books ad
sorry books ad
so let's try that again so there we go
okay
so i'm just gonna paste in a very
generic form here
for adding a book and all the fields of
a book
just so you don't have to watch me add
the form fields because
that's going to add a lot of time so let
me just do that
a few moments later
okay so here's what i added it's just a
basic form and there's nothing view
specific here yet
and there's some basic styles in here so
it doesn't
look too ugly it still looks very ugly
but
there we go and these categories are
hard-coded as well
okay so let's start making this dynamic
okay so the first thing i want to do is
populate these with the correct
categories
so let's go ahead and
grab some code from here
so the one with the categories let's
grab so let's grab this apollo query
and let's
go back to add book
let's paste it
right
underneath here
so underneath this form group
and let's
remove this
and let's just list the categories here
so let's put it as a div
take off this href
and let's get to the correct query so we
already have this it's uh
this is required in
and add slash
graphql
slash queries
slash categories
jql
and let's remove this click handler and
the class
and if i did this correctly this should
show the categories in our book view and
it does cool so we want this but we want
it in the
drop down
so let's just replace
this div with a select because that's
what we want
we just want to copy this
and each one of these is going to be
each one of these and the v4 so we'll
change the
option
and we will
add a value here
the value is category.id
and in here
it's just going to display the category
name
so this should work now let me
comment this out or just remove it
i'm gonna take this
move it in there
and this should now populate
the categories and it does cool
okay cool
okay so now i would like to add a v
model to all of these fields
and just hold them as state in this
component because we eventually have to
submit this to a back end
so let's go ahead and do that
so let's start with
this the model equals title
and i'm going to do the same for all of
the fields
this one is author
this one is
image
and obviously this is going to be
some sort of image picker component
or like a file uploader but
that's out of the scope of this
tutorial
uh description
v model
description
link
link
featured
featured
and for the select we can put a
category here
and now let's make some state
script
data
turn
so let's just put everything we
just defined so title
author
image description
link
featured will be false by default
and the default category is just one
okay let's see if this works
okay so we're not going to see any
changes here but if we open dev tools
let's see if
this reacts to changes
let's go into our
component
and
change
does this change it does cool author
image
description
link
featured
works
this
works awesome
okay now let's work on
that create a book
mutation
so let me go into graphql playground
first
and let's
try it out here
so it's gonna be mutation
i think i have one called createbook
and this takes in
the id
oh no no id
just uh whatever parameters you need to
create the book
title
new book
author
and all the other fields
okay so here is the mutation so let's
try this up
okay so that created a new one called
new book
let's just double check the database
so it should be number 25
and there it is cool and it added
everything we specified
in the query okay
so we can copy this
and let's go ahead and make a new query
under mutations
new mutation i mean
let's call it
ad book or create book
i'll name it ad book
but the actual mutation is called create
book
uh yeah just get your names right
great
book so let me just replace these
so i'm gonna put a bracket here
oops
i want it here
and paste that in
and then i'm going to replace that with
variables
okay and now let me just replace these
with
the variables
okay
so now back to ad book
let's make a new
submit handler on the form
where's the form here it is
at submit.prevent
let's call it
adbook
and let's go ahead and
make a method
methods
add book
and let's just see if this works
okay
add book adding book
and let's go into the documentation and
take a look at how to do mutations
so let's grab this
so this this apollo mutate
so it's all of this
i think it's all of this
so it's pretty long
and a lot of stuff we don't need so
let's just work with this
see if it's the right
indentation
so this closes
this okay
don't need this
okay so we don't need any of this
don't need that
but we do need the variables
and let's go ahead and just import this
instead of using this gql thing here so
let me
this
and we'll call it create ad book
yeah it's called ad book
and let's import that up
here just like we did in the last video
so
import add book
from
graphql
mutations
add book dot gql
okay
oh sorry this goes outside
and this can be
add book
and the variables
so let me just grab everything in here
see if we can just do this
and see if we can work some magic here
copy that
and say this dot
let's add
okay
i think that is it let's see if i did
everything correctly
so any errors no errors
cool
so if you're curious about what this web
socket is it has to do with
graphql subscriptions
which is a feature of graphql and
i haven't explored it yet in the
lighthouse package
but i think this is what this websocket
error is coming from where this
websocket air is coming from so
just ignore it for now
okay so let's see if this works
so this is what happens when it's
successful in this then callback after
the promise resolves
so
we just want to
console.log
the book
that is added and in our query we're
just returning
the id in a title
okay so let's try this
say great
book
great
author
and the image is going to be broken
like i said it's just a text field so
just make sure this image exists or
it's going to be broken
this is the description
same with the link
just make sure you add a proper link
see if this works and let's see if
this works so it should be two
category id two if it works
so it looks like it did work awesome
so there's the data coming back it's
just the id and the title
and just to double check
we can
check the database
and there should be a new one in here
and there is awesome
and two is correct for category id and
everything else looks like it worked
so what do we want to do
when
the promise resolves
so we want to clear this information
or in our case we just want to redirect
back home
so let's do that
so let's just do this
router
push
and let's just go back home
so
one more time
one more
author
image
i'm just gonna type gibberish
featured
biography so now this should redirect
to
the
[Music]
home page
and it does see if it's down here
and there it is
cool
and let's check the database
just to make sure it should be in there
27.
there it is cool
okay so now let's work on
editing a book
so we go into one of them
and then we want to be able to edit this
book
so we want a link in here so let's add
that link first
so let's go to book
and just underneath this
let's add two links here
let's just say
edit
and delete
and it's both give them a class of
what i name it i think of link margin
just to give it some
margin on the right and see how this
looks
all right let's put that in a div
let's just wrap it in a div like this
cool
okay so now it's on the bottom awesome
so let's start with editing
so let's go into our router
and make a new one for editing so i want
it to be box id slash
edit books id
slash edit
and let's name it
edit
let's name it edit book
okay
and i'm gonna
i'm gonna duplicate this one because
we're gonna be reusing a lot of the
logic here
duplicate
let's call it edit
book
and say edit book
let's change this to edit book
and down here
let's change it
to edit book actually no that was the
method right yeah
and let's change this one to update book
and we will import that
and we have to make that
new mutation
and changes to
okay so let's first
again play around in the playground
and let's check out how this works
so i'm gonna
paste that in because it's very similar
update book
but now we need an id
so let's update the one we just created
or the one we created in here so 25.
and
let's say new book
changed
andre changed
image
changed
changed amazon
changed
description and featured false category
2.
and we just want to return the id and
title see if this works
i think it's called update book
so it did work
let's see if all that stuff changed in
the database
25
so you saw all of that changed
cool
so let me grab this
and
let's do the same thing
say update book
let's paste that in
and let's add all the parameters in here
so we need
all of this stuff
let me just do this
okay
and
let's be a dollar sign here
they are mostly strings
so let me just do that and i will edit
this
id
this is required
this is required
these are not required this is a boolean
and the category isn't it
required
okay
and same for this change this oops
just add the
variable like that
and that should do it update
book
update book okay
and let's give that a try
so right now it is not going to populate
it with the information that it already
has
um
we'll do that
right after
so
it should go to 16 slash edit we'll put
the link here let me just put that right
now
so
edit book and book
this should be a router link
two
where's it slash books
slash id slash edit
so they should be
book dot id
okay
does that work
oh what's wrong
data.book.id
okay
okay so yeah like i said this should
show the information about the book but
we haven't done that yet
i just want to
check that it does update but i think i
forgot something here
so in our
update book so we have the id here but
for editbook we don't have the id here
as state
actually we don't need it as state but
we do need it when we're passing it to
the
mutation so let's just add that id is
this dot route
dot params dot id
so let's save
that and
let me just
go to
one that i created down here
just so i don't edit one the ones that
has a proper image so
this one
edit
okay so
title is
27 since that's the id
author
change
and for this stuff let me just
do this
let's make it asdf for all of them
featured and
science
and what did i do
after
i just oh it's gonna go back here i
don't want to do this
let's just see if it works
and seems like it did work
there you go 27 let's check the database
there you go so added all that i mean it
updated all that
and everything seems correct
so where do i want it to go
after we go in here
we edit it i want to go back to the read
page
so
[Music]
instead of
this we just wanted to go to
slash books
slash
this
route.params.id
okay
but yeah like i said we want this
information to be populated as we hit
edit so this has to be populated with
the correct information
so we already have a query for that and
we already did that in
the book view so let's do something
similar
so let's import
book
from
let's grab this
queries
book dot gql
and instead of using the apollo query
component i'm just going to do it the
original way where we just use that
apollo
field here
because i need to do something after it
is successful
and i don't think there's a way to do
that with the component so let me show
you what i mean
so
if you go into the api reference there
is the example i will show you in here
so this result
hook is what i want to
make use of
so this is this code is executed after a
successful
query
and i need that because i want to update
the state
once we have a successful query
so let me just grab all this and
remove what i don't need later
okay
so i'm gonna put it right here
okay so
so let's
make a state to hold the book
so i'll put in here
and it'll be null by default
and this is what we want to populate
book
and the query we already have imported
up here so we want to be booked
so we can remove this
and
variables
so we have to use it
this way is the correct way
if you look at the original example
over here
it is just
where's variables
variables
yeah it's just a
an object here
but we have to use a method
and
i'll tell you why
um
as i write the code
so i tried doing it this way originally
and it didn't get the route parameters
which we need because that's the
variable we need so
let me just
show you what i mean
this
that route that perhaps so you have to
wait for the route params to be
available and this is the way to do it
let's do that
and the
variable we want is the id
and it'll be
this that route that params.id so yeah
like i said if you just did this
like this
then it wouldn't work the route param
won't be available so you have to use
this method
okay so we don't need this
but we do need
this result
and we don't need any of this other
stuff
and i don't think i need this
okay
so all i want to do here is just update
this state over here
just so this can
this information can show here in the
template
so i just want to do
this that title
equals
so it's going to be data.book.title
and i want the same for the rest of the
states this is going to be author
this will be
um
image
and category is going to be a bit
different it's just going to be data dot
category dot id because that's the way
the
data's coming back
so if i did this correctly
this should work hopefully
and it does cool so as you can see the
data is populated with the correct
information
so which one is this this is number
three
so if i were to change this in the back
end this should update
number three
sapiens
changed
and let me just save that
if i refresh this it should be reflected
there
cool
so one more test here to see if this
works
i don't want to change this one because
it's going to change the image
it's changed let's make it not featured
and let's make it go to biography
update book they should go back to the
view page it does
and it looks like it worked
check the database
refresh
there we go
awesome
okay now let's work on deleting and that
should be it so i want to delete this
and then i wanted to go back to the main
page with this deleted
so let's go ahead and do that
so let's go to our book dot view
it's right here
and let's add a script here
we have to import that
delete query
delete book mutation i mean so import
we'll make this in a second delete book
from
graphql
mutations
delete
book dot gql
okay let's make that
late
book and let's go to graphql playground
and check out how to delete a book
so it's just mutation
you need the id and that's it i think
oh sorry
delete book you need the id
let's delete
the last one here
27.
and that's it we can return the id of
the deleted thing and even the title if
you want
and that should be
gone cool
so let's grab this
let's paste it in
here
should be
an id
required
and then id
is id
okay
back to book
let's put a
click handler on this
the delete
link
let's do prevent so it doesn't
scroll to the top of the page so delete
book
and let's
add a methods in here
delete
book
so this dot
apollo
dot mutate
mutation
delete
book
and variables
we can just do it the normal way so id
this dot route the params dot id
and then then smooths up
data
just going to log it
and let's
go back to the home page so this router
push
home
and
that should do it
see if this works
okay so let's go home and it's deleted
the last one let's refresh this
let's go all the way here let's go to 26
great book
okay let's delete it
okay that looked like it worked
26 should be here
okay it's still here
okay so it is still here
that's because it's cached
so if i refresh this should be gone
so yeah
we have to handle that case let me just
show you the database should be gone
um i don't really do too much research
or i didn't think about it too much of
how to
solve that issue of caching we obviously
want caching if it was like a real app
because that would save hitting the
database
but for this case
i just removed caching completely
which is not ideal but it does work
so
i think it's called fetch policy
so if i change this to
no cache
that is not gonna cash at all
no cash
so let's try it again
let's delete
new book changed
delete
and
that should be gone
it is gone awesome it should be out of
the database too
awesome
so there you have it guys we've done a
lot of work here on our front end and
now have complete crud functionality for
all of our books
so a few things i would consider if this
were a real app the first one would be
so remember when we did categories here
this is just happening in the browser
say for example you wanted to send a
link to someone with the specific
category
selected
that wouldn't work
so what i would consider is adding a
route to save the state
so that would be like categories slash
four as we click this and then you can
send this off to someone and that would
preserve the state
so that's one thing i would consider
doing
another thing i would consider doing is
using nuxt for server-side rendering
mainly just for seo if you care about
seo
and it also makes routing slightly
easier
so that's another thing i'll consider
using next
and yeah i think that's it for now
i'd like to style our graphql app with
tailwind css
you've seen the design throughout the
videos already so let's go ahead and get
started
so there's the design we'll be
recreating and
yeah let's get started
so let's go to tailwind
the docs and let's install it
so npm install taylor and css
okay
next is to create
a tailwind config
so just do this command
and we'll name it tailwind.js
okay win.js
okay
next is to
create a css entry point
so let me just grab this
and let's put it in
let's put it in assets let's put in here
just call it main css
okay what's next
next we can
just paste this into our
[Music]
post css.config.js
let's do that
i think there's a post css config.js
there it is
so let me just
do that
okay
all right
and then
that's it so let's remove our styles
here
the default styles i think it's an app
view
so there's some default style here
so i'm going to remove all of this
and i'm going to import our main css
so source equals
dot slash assets
main css i believe
and then let's just see if this works
um let's just put something here
p dot pg blue text white
lorem 20 okay see if this works
and i think i forgot to change
this
so it's not tailwind.js
okay so there we go there is tailwind
working and we can start
okay so the first thing i want to do is
change the font so the font i'm using in
my design is
roboto so let's import that and use it
so i'm going to go into app
view actually now i'm going to import it
in here
so i'm just going to paste in the import
from google fonts
and i'm using just the regular weight
and the bold weight
and now in our app view
i can set the font stack here
um
font signs
let's make it anti-aliased as well
and let's make everything black
let's make sure to
update the font stacks
it's right here
so let's put rubato on top
okay
or i can just move this up
that's fine
okay now i think it's using roboto
let's double check
it is not
i'm sorry this is supposed to be
class
okay that should work now
okay that looks like roboto
awesome that's roboto cool
okay so let's start with the
header here or the nav
so let's do that okay
let me just remove this
and will you make use of this
so i didn't have and we'll add a class
and it's going to make it bg
purple dark i'll just use tailwind's
default colors
and
i want a container here so the whole
thing is constrained within a container
and tailwind does come with one but you
have to uncomment it
in the tailwind config
container
so yeah i want to center it and i do
want some padding so let me uncomment
that
and let's put these within a within a
container
okay
and let's see how this looks
okay cool
so i'm gonna want the logo here and then
these two on the right
so let's make it flex
right here
flex i want items center so they're
vertically
in at the center and justify between
to send them to the left and the right
let's add some padding
so now the first flex item is going to
be the logo
so let's add a new container for that
logo here
it's link and i wanted to go home so
we'll do that it's an image
and i already have it in here
so svg
let's do slash
assets slash logo.svg
and we'll do logo here
and then the second flex item is going
to be these two
so let's wrap it in a div
and let's see how this looks
okay looking pretty good
let's just fix these
so i'm gonna
do this
class equals
so i want to be white
and i want to have a hover just of a
change of color when you hover so let's
do text gray light when you hover over
it and i want some padding on just this
one
okay
it looks pretty good
and i want to remove the underline first
okay that pipe is right here
and i want to remove the underline on
all of the links so we'll do it in here
so we'll just add it after this a
text decoration
none
cool
okay now let's move on to the next
section which should be the hero
so this
part over here
and it's within a container as well but
it has a great background so we have to
do the same thing
so let's do that
so i'm going to put it in home because
it only appears in home
so let's
just put it up here
let's make some roof right here okay i'm
gonna name it hero
i want some bg
gray
light and i want the margin bottom of
24.
and then this is where the container
goes
and
just put some stuff in here
see how it looks
okay looking good
and again i want to flex
make it a flex container and then this
will be one item and this this will be
the other item and i can justify content
space between
so let's do that
so it's going to be flex
item center
justify
between
and let's give it some padding
so now the two flex items should be
the first one on the left is where the
where this goes
so let's say book recommendation site
built with
graphql
so let's make it an h1
book
recommendation
site built with graphql
and then underneath it i'll have
built with
variable
i should just paste this in
too bad you're watching me type it
graphql
okay and the other flex item is going to
be the hero image and
i also have
an svg for that
and some assets
it's called hero svg
put the hero in here
okay so let's see how this looks
okay it doesn't seem to be flexing what
i do around here
i spelled it wrong that's why
that's great
okay cool
i actually don't want item center here
so let's move that
okay
so for this i don't want it to be the
full width so i just want it to be like
here let's add a class
let's see if i can do width
three-fourths or something like that
okay that doesn't do anything
let me add a margin here
just push it down a bit okay cool
so i want let's try putting the width on
here on the h1 and also on
this
so class equals width three-fourths
okay so that's better
and let's just put a margin here after
the h1
say mb4
cool
and the line height looks a bit too
tight here
so let's do
normal i think
okay
okay now let's add i think i have
buttons here yeah so the view books and
the view screencasts button
buttons
so let's go ahead and do that
so it's going to be another section here
and it's going to be flex as well
and items center
and let's make them anchor tags
class equals
bg
purple
dark
text
white
i want to be rounded
px4 py4
let's get a margin right
and i want it to be slightly different
when you hover over it so let's do
however it's slightly lighter
and it's going to be called view books
see how that looks
okay looking pretty good
just put a margin after the paragraph
right
here
say six
okay
and let's do the other button
so it's going to have a border
border
purple
dark
border solid
let's be rounded as well
it's gonna be purple
dark
px4
py4
and hover
bg
purple and hover text
white
this one's called
view screencasts
okay
okay looking pretty good hover works
awesome okay let's continue working on
the next section which is the grid of
books
so let me just turn on my grid here
and as you can see it's in quarters so
one quarter here and one quarter for
each of the books
so let's go ahead and do that
so i'm going to go into the tailwind
docs and if you just search for grid
we'll just make use of this and change
it to our needs
so i want something with a gap
so
let's look for that column spacing okay
so this one is in thirds
and
yeah just make use of this
okay so where am i
i'm gonna put it right after the hero so
this is the hero let me just end this
and let's see what we get with this
this should be thirds see if that works
okay so it does work
cool
so let's wrap this in a container
cool
okay
this is not aligned here
i think i don't need
this one
so let's remove this
and this one as well
okay see how that looks
okay so now that's lined up i think
yeah cool
and we want quarters
so let's make
one more of these and then make them
quarters
so one third
should be four
okay
okay looking good
and i want the gap to be a bit bigger so
i'm going to change
this
these
these twos
i'll change these to four
okay
awesome
so if you take a look at the design we
obviously want several books and we're
going to be looping over some sort of
variable that has all the books
so we wanted to wrap
uh so let me show you what i mean
so right now if i can just keep adding
more of these then it's not going to
wrap
it's just going to stay on the same
line here we do want it to wrap so if we
add flex wrap it will wrap
okay that's what we want
let's just add a margin bottom on them
as well
so for these let's just put
mb say 12 or something
okay it looks good
however we don't want the whole thing to
wrap because
this first section the first quarter is
just the menu and then we want these to
wrap
so let's make some changes here
so what i'm going to do is going to have
the first one to be one quarter and then
the next one to be three quarters and
then within that
i'll have more
items
let's see how that looks first
okay that looks good and from within
here we want these items to wrap
so let's add
flex to this one
flex flex wrap
and then these ones we want to be one
third each so
if class equals with one third
let's add that px4
and the
mb12 so let's see how this looks
let's just say lorem 20 or something
let's add a few
see if that works
okay so that is looking like what we
want let's add a few more see for wraps
and it does so that is looking like the
layout that we want cool
okay so this first section is where we
want
the the navigation to be
so let's do that
so here's where the nav goes
okay
so let's go ahead and grab that
and this is the one so let's grab this
whole thing
and let's just see how that looks
right
here
let's reinvent that
and let's see what we have
okay cool let's make this an unordered
list with some list items
so here
instead of a div let's make a ul
and these are still
anchor tags but
they have to be list items so let's do
that for these
and the same for this one
see where that gets us
okay uh
i didn't do the list item correctly for
this one
so yeah this should be a list item
because that's the thing we're iterating
over
so we don't need this anymore
but
this should be an anchor tag now
let's see if this works
okay excellent
and we also want
the add book
here so i think i have it down here
yeah so let's just add this one too
at the bottom
so after this loop we just add this
and let's wrap that in an li as well
okay
so i don't want these numbers i was just
there so i can see the id
okay
and let's remove the
bullet points
so for the ul i can do
class equals list reset
and let's also make it a bit larger
okay
and if you look at the design
the spacing between them is pretty
liberal so let's add some margin
for all of these
here
here
i'm going to put it here
oh there's already a class on that one
let me just add that after so class
equals amb6
let's take this out and
mb6
okay cool looks good
and let's just remove these purple links
so we can do
here on the
class
so let me just do it for these ones
first
so text
black and let's also make a hover state
hover
text gray darkest
so let me just crop copy this
oh there's two there's one one
and i have to add it to this too
class equals this and this one too i
think
okay
looking good there's the overstate very
subtle but that's good for me
okay looking pretty good
okay so now let's work on the book
images here
so
right here they should be in here and
they should be looped over
so let me just grab
one of these from
i'm gonna grab this one here so i'll
take care of the different cases later
on let me just
try to get one working
and displaying correctly
so i'm gonna remove these ones
and just work with
just this one okay so let's
paste this in and see what we get
okay
okay so it is not in the grid format
that we want
see what's going on here
so we want the thing that we're
iterating over to have these classes
so this actually belongs in
here
where we're iterating over the
books
so let's see if that works
okay so i made it smaller but still not
quite what we want
that's because
the parent component of this
should have the flex container so let's
move this
and here
so this is the parent of this so
i think this should work
okay there we go
so yeah there's a lot of nested divs
here
and
yeah so
that should be fine actually
so let me just move the
title and the author underneath
so i'm going to move this underneath the
book
okay
and you can see it's not a block element
so let's just wrap this
in a div
okay looking better
and
the books images are almost
the same size but you can see some of
them are not
the same height
so we can specify a hard height on the
image
so
here we can add a class on the image
you just put h64 was what i found worked
for me
see how that looks
okay so that looks pretty good now now
everything's aligned
okay and let's add just a small margin
underneath it
okay looks pretty good
now we can work on
the styling of the title and the author
so
it's just bolded and
slightly lighter color
okay so let's do that
so i'm also going to move the id i don't
want that i just want the title
okay inside a class on this
let's make it slightly bigger
let's make it bold
and is it a link color right now it is
so let's make it black
let's make it hover
text gray darkest
and let's put a select margin on it
okay let's see if the helper works okay
there's a subtle hover color change
there
and let's work on the author
and i just want the color to be a bit
lighter
text gray
darkest
okay
so that looks pretty good to me
okay cool
um
let's also add
the link
right now it's just too uh
it's all it's only on the title let's
put it on the image as well
so
let's just grab this router link and we
can just paste it
here
let's close that
and i can close the router link here
see if that works
okay
it does cool
um i think this has to be
block
or the margin
it doesn't apply there we go so that
moved down slightly cool
okay now let's work on getting this
other stuff to work because right now we
only have this case working
so let's go ahead and do that
so if you look down here we have
vf categories all else if it's featured
else it's just one of the categories
and we can do the same here
and we can just put the conditional on
the actual apollo query
so we can do this
and then we can
grab the other cases as well so i'm
going to copy this
let's put it in here
and
that case is
what's that case
v else if
it's featured
so i'll do that
for this case let's put it in here
and then let's do the last case here
it's just vl so i'm just gonna grab all
this
and let's put a vls on this
and see if this works
sorry i think i put this in the wrong
place this should be
up here
yeah up here sorry
yep
put that in there
that should work now
see
okay so there we go let's see if this
works now
okay
we have to
change that but you can see that these
are changing
awesome
okay so for featured you have to do the
same thing so let's do that
so featured is this one
and what do we do again
we
added this class
for the thing that we're iterating over
so we're iterating over this let's add
the class
and then for here we added class equals
flex
flex
wrap
so let's do the same thing here
class equals flex
flex wrap and the thing we're iterating
over gets that
class see if that
works cool
featured okay so that's working
and these work too
but now these
are in a different format as well
so we can just do the same thing we did
up here
for the all category
or we can
just extract this to a component
and make use of
and reuse it down there so that's
probably the smart thing to do
so let me just copy this let's comment
it out
and let's make one called
a new component called book
listing
and then we'll pass in the book
cool
let me close that
and let's make that component uh we're
making points
book
listing dot view
template
space that in
and we're going to accept a book prop
script
props let's just use the array syntax
it's going to be a book
okay
let's import that in here
down here
[Music]
say
import
book listing
from
components
slash book
listing
view
and then we can use this
in here
and see if i did everything correctly
okay so it looks like i did
let me just refresh to
make sure and it does work
so we have that new book component and
now we can just make use of that
in the other ones
so let me
grab this
and i'll just leave this in here so
if you look at the code you'll see that
in there
but
we don't need this anymore
what is this
so yeah we can just remove this
and say book listing
and same for this
book listing
okay let's see if that works so all
works featured
i don't know why that doesn't work
why is there no image
oh sorry i forgot to
add the
image into the component
so it's here still that's why i was
working in the first case so let me just
grab that
save that now the first one shouldn't
have
okay so now we can just add that in the
book listing
sorry about that that should work now
there we go featured awesome
awesome everything works
and is looking pretty good now awesome
i say awesome a lot
okay let's quickly make it responsive
not too much work here
so
the navigation is fine since there isn't
too much
in the nav
i just want this to stack
after a certain breakpoint
so i'm going to make it
i think 992 is the large breakpoint
right there
so we'll just work with that one
okay so let's see what's going on here
so up here
so on mobile we want it to be
flex direction of column so it stacks
but on large screens we want to be flex
row large screens we also want justify
between
and that should stack now i think
and it does cool
um
i just want some margin on top of the
image
so let's do that for the image container
so that is right here
so on mobile i want mt
say 12 let's say 10.
okay
that's fine
and then large
empty zero
okay
see if the normal one still works okay
it is cool
this looks pretty good
um
this we can make
full width too
it might look weird when it's still kind
of big
but you can add more breakpoints if you
want
so let's make it full width here so this
thing right here
so
on large screens
we want with width three fourths same
with this one
but with full
on
mobile and up
with full
okay cool so that looks pretty good
awesome
that's that
and for this i just want to stack this
so again it's it probably looks fine at
a certain point like here you can still
fit like maybe two
but i'm just gonna stack it
so first
um
remember how we had one fourth and three
fourths let's stack that first
so one fourth right here
so large screen we want one-fourth
and we'll pile it up let's do that
and same for the three-fourths one
with full large width three-fourths
okay so that's the actual
and then we also want the same for
the thirds here
so do for each case let's just do it for
this one
sorry not this it's the categories for
this case
so right here
large
width full
and
that to anything okay there we go cool
again that's kind of
still a lot of room here but
i think you'll get what i'm trying to do
here
so let's just put this on the other
cases too
let me just grab this
so
here
and
here
so now it should work for all these
cases let me just refresh it first
so all cool featured
cool
oh this is the other thing we can just
delete this this is all we had before
and
all these cases
awesome so it is responsive now let me
get rid of all this
stuff after what's this
this is the container so that's the end
of it
and container
so all of this stuff
what is this and that's probably the
whole container
yeah so all the stuff we don't need
cool let's see if everything still works
awesome it's responsive
let's see if
large screens don't work
and it does
okay let's quickly make this view work
not going to make it too pretty just
just a little bit i think i do have a
design for it
yeah let's just
do something like this
okay so i think it's called book view
so
book.view
let's just
add a container
okay
and
in here is where we can style it
so i'm going to add
flex
let's add a margin
and i'm going to do a responsive at the
same time here just so i can save some
time
okay so the first flex item i want that
to be the image
so let me just make a div for it and
then i'll move the image inside of it
and then the other flex item
should have these inside of it
oops
and even the stuff i want inside
oh yeah let me just grab these as well
okay
see how this looks
okay
and
yeah let me just style this real quick
so
uh the title first
class equals
text 4xl
font
bold
for the author we want
text
to excel
text gray
darkest
let's add a margin bottom
and i think i don't have the description
so let's add that
text
lg
and we can leave that
and say letting normal
and
data book
description
okay see how it looks
okay
so i don't want this to be full with
this part so let's change that
so up here
uh so let's do mobile at the same time
so mobile i want with full but for large
queens i just want to be
two-thirds
and on mobile margin left of zero but on
large screens
let me have a margin too
large greens empty zero
and large greens
ml16 margin left 16
and that's looking pretty decent
and i also want a view link button here
so let's do that quickly
so right under the description
let's add a new container let's make it
like that
and let's
add
href of
data.book.link let's make sure to bind
that
okay
and then
let's make it open in a new window
class equals
so this is just uh
the same button as
on the main screen
so this button right here
okay let's see how that looks
okay it looks pretty good and this
should open
the link
awesome
and this is pretty good too let me just
add a
i'm going to remove this link margin
actually let's use tailwinds
classes and i want a uh
mid dot in between where's edit
this one's edit
that i want
mid dot
so that looks pretty good to me
and let's check if response works
and it does cool
okay so
um
the edit
and the create screens are the same so
i'm gonna do one of them
and i'm not gonna make it look
too nice i don't actually have a design
for that i'll work on the create one but
let's just make it so it's not ugly
uh so create book i think i named it
ad book
oh sorry that's the query
add book
view
so let's first add a container on this
let's add a margin top too
okay
and
i'm just going to make use of the styles
i already have down here so
type equals text
so i'm going to paste in some stuff to
add some
because uh tailwind and the resets
remove the borders for the text areas
so i just added that back in with this
okay
and it's gonna do
label display block
and
that is
good enough for me let me just add some
spacing here
create book
mb4
and for all the labels
so
i'm going to add
maybe a font bold on these
class equals font bold
and maybe a margin bottom of two
okay that looks pretty decent
so yeah you can do the same for the edit
book but i'm pretty happy overall with
how the styling is
and
yeah
so let's do a final check make sure
everything still works
um
so we can change the categories
okay
cool
can we add a book
just add something
add author
let's just add an image that exists so
it looks decent
awesome new book
uh let's say amazon
let's make it featured and let's put it
in
business
and there it is right there cool
let's see if edit works
should work i didn't change anything
there
yeah you can restyle this but
change
update
awesome
so there you have it guys we managed to
style our graphql application using
tailwind css
i'd like to deploy our graphql app to a
real production server
i've received a few questions on how to
do deployment so let's go ahead and do
that
so i'll be using laravel forge to deploy
the level back end
and for the front end i'll also use
forge but i'll also show you how to do
it with netlify
so i've made a few changes to get this
app ready for production so let me just
go over them here
so the first is in the back end here i
am in the git repo
and let me just go to the commits and
this last one i mentioned in a few
videos
ago that
you should use absolute urls so before i
just had the
name of the book file book image
and now i have an absolute path and i'm
using cloudnary to host the images
so this is probably what i do if this
were a real app as cloudnary is the best
service for hosting images
as it offloads some of the load off of
your server and is also a cdn
so yeah i just changed all of these to
cloudnary links
and for the view end
let's go into here check out the commits
and
so i changed the
book url
to
instead of relative it now just getting
it from the back end
so that's one change i made same here
and here
i made two changes
uh for this one i'm now using
so i changed the end point to the actual
endpoint we'll be using
i'm going to put it to this domain
because that's sort of a test domain i
use
and i also added a
emv file so
let me show you in the actual code
so i added a
emv.development.local file
so the way this is going to work is if
we're running in development
then it's going to get it from the
environment file but if we build it for
production which we'll do in a second
then it will
use the correct production endpoint so
here's the local file
and it's just
pointing at the development server
okay
so those are the changes i made
and
i think there's one more yeah i just
turned off this web sockets just to get
rid of those annoying errors in the
console
and yeah that's it
so let's go ahead and go into forge and
start here
so i'm going to go into forge i'm gonna
go into
laravel e-commerce
and i'll make a new one
so like i said i'm going to
deploy it to this domain
booksql.laravelecommerce.ca
so let's do that
and
general php laravel and public that's
fine
so let's add that site
okay let's go into it
and let's install a git repo
and the git repo is
tray himself slash
books ql
level
okay install the repo
okay so before i deploy it i want to
make a new database because this
server already has a default database
for the
laravel ecommerce app that's on it so i
am going to make a new database
so just go here database
and let's make a new one here
let's call it booksql
and we'll add a user later on
i mean
right now
so
we can add one here let's do books
books ql underscore user
and this is a secret password i'm going
to delete this after so it doesn't
matter
and can access this new books ql
database we just made
and let's add that user booksql user
secret password
and it's installing
and it's done okay
so i'm going to ssh into the server and
change the dot env file so let's go
ahead and do that
so let me just ssh forge at laravel
ecommerce example dot ca
okay so that new one should be there and
there it is right there booksql
dot laravel ecommerce example.ca
and there is an environment file so i'm
gonna
go ahead and change the database
credentials
to
the one we just created
okay so i changed the credentials there
let me just quit out of here and now we
can deploy it
so go back into our
site
and let's deploy it and hopefully it
works
and it looks like it did work
uh let's check over here
so books ql dot laravel
ecommerce
example.ca
okay so it did work
i just want to quickly add ssl
it's like two clicks so let's just do
that
and obtain certificate and that should
do it
okay that's active let's see if it's
https now
and it is cool
so now we should be able to
hit our graphql endpoint on this new
server so let's open the graphql
playground
and go to
that endpoint
slash graphql
graph ql
and that should work let me just make
this bigger
and
yeah
this query should work let's see if it
works
oh so there's no data in there yet i
have to
seed the database
so let's go into here
and this is the app
we can do php artisan db seed
yes
and now this should work
so there you go there's all the books
in our new server
okay now let's work on our front end so
all we have to do is
run the
npm
run build command
so
let me just open up a new tab here
books ql
view
okay and i just have to
run this command npm run
build
and this will make a new dist folder
which will package up everything we need
to build for production
so there you go we have this new dist
folder with all the files we need and we
can just
use this to upload to our server so you
should definitely make use of
purge css
to make your file size much lower for
tailwind css and i actually have a video
on that which i will link to below
and let's just take a look at this in
our code
so we have a new dist folder here
and we'll just be uploading this but
let's just make sure that it is using
not using this one this is the
development one but using the production
this one so laravel ecommerce example so
let's just
double check and
search for it here
okay so it's not that file it's probably
this file
okay so there it is
so we know it built correctly
so in theory before we throw this up on
the server we should actually be able to
run it here so
i'm just going to go into the disk
folder
and i'm going to run my own server
and i have one called
i have an
alias called server and it just runs a
php server
so i'm just going to in the local in the
current directory so i'm going to do
that
and it's running in localhost 888 and
this should work
so there we go and it's pulling from the
actual server
let's make sure it works and it does
cool
so let's throw this up on
forge first so i'm going to make a new
site
again on laravel ecommerce
and i'm going to call it
books
so books
dot
laravel
ecommerce example.ca
not to be confused with books ql where
where our backend lives so this is just
a static html
so the
web root will just be the root which is
fine
and let's go ahead and add this
okay it's done let's
add ssl
so let's go into it actually
add ssl
okay
okay that's done
so if we hit this so it should be books
there should be a default page there
and there is cool
so if you want to see that on the server
it should be
here so there it is books dot
laravel ecommerce example.ca
and there's the stat index php so this
is where
everything in the dist folder goes so if
you just drop it in here it should work
so we can set a git repo if we want but
i'm just going to do it the
old-fashioned way
and just ftp it in so i'm going to use
my ftp app
transmit and let me just open it up
and there it is kind of small sorry
about that i can't zoom in so it's just
books
and i'm just
gonna think i have it here it's gonna
drag it in
so
the dist folder
i'm gonna delete this
and it's gonna grab everything in this
so everything in here and just drag it
in
okay that's done
so now
this should work
and it does awesome
so
let's try
so this works let's try adding a book
so add a book
actually let me get let me just grab
the url for one of the images because
i'm going to be using that so copy image
address
add a book
new book
andre's author image let's paste that in
this is an awesome book
link
amazon
featured and put it in
biography
at book
and it should be down here and there it
is and yeah it works
awesome
okay so let me show you how to do this
with netfly it's that simple
let's go to netlify
and log in
and all we have to do is drag in that
dist folder
so let me just
go up one drag in the dist folder
and that is it let's give it a second
and i think it's done and it gave us
this random domain
and it has https on it already
and since it's pulling from the same
back end there it is it should have that
new book we just added
and it should be right there cool and
everything still works
now if you wanted to add a custom domain
you can totally do that and i have a
video on netflix that show you shows you
how to do that
so check that out if you are interested
so there you have it guys we've deployed
both the front end and back end of our
graphql application using both forge and
netify
i'm not going to keep these urls live as
it's just taking up extra server
resources and it's something else i
don't want to maintain
but you saw exactly how i did it and can
set it up on your own if you need to
i'd like to show you how you can call
graphql queries from within your laravel
app
so i just finished up a graphql series
with laravel as the graphql server and
view as the client
so i was wondering how i can make
graphql queries from within laravel as
the client
so it's the same case if you're just
building a traditional server rendered
app and you need to make http requests
you'd probably make use of a library
like guzzle or curl
i want to see how to do the same but for
graphql
so i'll show you a few ways and a few
packages to accomplish this
so the first one is this package here
which is specific for php
and i actually have a laravel app
scaffolded out here already
and we'll
just make a use of that so let's just
composer require this
okay
and let's see how to use this so it says
within oauth2 provider we'll do it
without
okay so it looks like it's instantiating
it here
passing in the graphql endpoint here
and then here's the graphql query here
and some variables and there's a
response
so yeah all these libraries just use
guzzle under the hood
because if you look at graphql queries
they're just http requests
and
guzzle is the most popular one for php
so let's go ahead and do this
i'm just going to work in the routes
file
so i'll just work in here and paste
everything in here
so let's paste that in
and i am going to
make use of
this endpoint that we did in
the graphql series if you don't know if
you haven't seen that
i made an app a book recommendation app
and this is the endpoint for that
so let's grab this
and it's paste it in here
and here is where our query goes
so this operator i actually didn't know
what that was i had to look it up it's
just a way to do strings
but
that's
doesn't look
right to me because i've never used it
before so i'll just use normal strings
and we can just close it here
and we don't need this and this
should should still work
okay so let's just paste in
this query we have here
that we know works because we can see it
here
so i'll get rid of this
paste it in
and
this
should work so we don't have any
variables
so
we can just leave it actually
i think it will just ignore it
and after this let's just tie and dump
the response see if we get anything
okay let's try this out
okay so it looks like we get a response
and let's see what we have here so
there's our books right there
so we can also do
you can see the response is an array
if you want the response to be
the actual books you can just do
response
get data
it just
it makes it less nested
so there you go
cool so that's the first way
actually let's take a look at how to do
variables
so first let's
change this one to use the other query
which has variables
which is
uh
querying for one book
so this would be
yeah just passing the id
say we want three
this should work
there we go
so let's see how to do that in here
so let's just change the
query up here so book
id
is id
and title author and we just have to
accept
the parameters in here
so let's say get book we can name it i
don't think you have to name it but
let's name it anyways
id is of type id and it's required
and
that
should do it and the variables we have
to change
let's see this is hardcoded in so we
don't need this one so the id
is
just put
three in here
and this should work as well
there we go there's that book
and there is that book with id of three
so let's see how we can make use of
mutations so let's quickly do a mutation
here
so
we have one called create book
create book and i think you have to pass
it a title
new book
and author
say andre and a category
let's say
just one so it's an int
and let's say id
and title
okay okay so 35 is that new book we just
created
and we can do the same thing in our code
here
so let's put in the variables first so
i'm going to do title
awesome new book
and
the author
is
andre
and the title uh sorry the category
is just an end so let's say three
okay now let's get the query
i mean the mutation we just did here
so we can just copy this
and paste it in here
let me just reinvent that
and let's use the variables instead of
hard coding here
it's going to be title
author
and category
okay
and let's accept the params up here
so let's call it create book as well
and say title
is a string required
author
string required
category
int required
okay and you can change this to mutation
as well but i'll just leave it as query
should still work the same way
and if i did this correctly this should
make a new book from within our code
and that didn't seem to work
i think i have an extra
closing brace here
so yeah this one is not closing anything
let me just delete this one
and let's try that again
so there we go
create a new one called awesome new book
and that's how you do mutations
cool
okay so let's take a look at how to use
just guzzle
so like i said earlier graphql queries
are just basic http requests
and you're just passing in json
so let me show you what i mean so if i
go to my rest client which is insomnia
here i have the endpoint for
the graphql
and like i said if you just pass it some
json you can you can actually do a
graphql query here as well but we'll
just take a look at how to do it
with json
so if you just pass it
a query
and then the graphql query in here
so for example we'll do query let's do a
one line
books
and we want the
title and the author
this
should work
i think this has to be a string as well
let's see
okay so let's try
this and there we go
so this is the response that we get when
we're
using graphql so it's the same thing we
just have to make an http request and
pass in some json with the key as query
and then the
graphql query in here
so with that knowledge we can actually
just use guzzle
and just pass in some json using guzzles
functions
so let's do
that so i'm going to make a new
route here
oops
route call okay
and it's called a let's call it guzzle
and since guzzle is a dependency
for this other pack package we just used
we can just use it
so let's do client equals new
[Music]
causal
http
client
and let me paste in some code here
and this is what makes the
response actually
i have to
add the client
sorry the response here response
is client and it's a post request
to the
endpoint books ql
parable.test
graphql
and then the second parameter is this
thing i pasted in
so that just
some json to the
request
okay
what is this complaining about
okay
okay
so um let's see
let's just die and dump
the response
actually we have to dine up the response
i have to get the body
and me to get the contents just so we
can see what's coming back
okay
let's see if i did this correctly
and let's hit the guzzle end point
what did i do wrong here
i think i'm missing an opening
array square bracket here
and then a closing one here
okay sorry some formatting issues there
let's see if this works
okay so there you go there's the
response for our graphql query
let's test
just json decode this so we can get it
as an array
there you go so there's our data cool
and these are all the books in our
database cool
and we can also do the same thing we did
above uh if you just want to
get a specific book we can just pass in
an id
this is hardcoded in
id1
that should work
there we go there's that book
and you can also do mutations if you
like
so let's quickly do a mutation here
sorry this is a mutation
yeah this is a mutation
and it's called create book
and it needs a title
say new book
it needs an author
and it needs a category
and we'll return that okay see if this
works
and there we go it created this new one
awesome with id of 37.
okay one more way i want to show you and
that's just using a wrap another wrapper
around guzzle
called
zttp
this is the
http library i prefer it just makes it
easier
so
there is i'm looking at the tests here
and there's one
that lets you pass in json like this so
it's going to grab this
actually i have to install it first but
let me just grab that paste it in
let's call it zttp
and let's try this out
let's install it first
and you actually have to do slash
like this okay
and let's do composer require
i think it's what is it kite tail
kite tails http
sorry that should be a forward slash
okay so that's done let's take a look
here
so
let's put in the url here
we just need one
key and that's going to be query
and then the value is the
graphql query so let's
quickly do what we did before query
say books
say title author
close that out
and
that should work
let's just dine dump
response
json
and let's see if this works
so let's do zttp
and there we go there's our data
there's all our books and we can do
exactly the same thing we did in here
we can pass in parameters and we can
also do mutations which i won't show you
because it's exactly the same as we did
here
so there you have it guys we've managed
to query our graphql server from within
a laravel app
we've taken a look at three ways to do
so
so you can pick which way you enjoy the
most
i'd like to take a look at a graphql
server package called graphql laravel
this is similar to the lighthouse
package which we used in my graphql
series to build out in app
they are both similar in that they are
both graphql servers however they take a
different approach which we'll take a
look at throughout this video
if you haven't seen at least the first
video in that graphql series definitely
check it out as i'll be making
comparisons between both packages
so these packages both make use of the
graphql php package which is a vanilla
php implementation
so this graphql laravel package is more
similar to that whereas the lighthouse
package
sort of conforms more to the graphql
spec
and makes use of heavy directives
so if you don't know what that means
don't worry we'll be going over
everything in this video
okay so let's get started let's install
this i have a laravel app running
already
and i didn't do anything to it yet
so let's
composer required it
okay
let's
publish the config
okay
and that is it
okay so let's do some quick setup in
that first video
uh where we took a look at this
lighthouse package which is right here
we took a look at an example where it
was a basic blog implementation so the
models the models we had were users
comments and posts
so we'll do the same thing we'll just
have users in posts and the relationship
will be a user has many posts and a post
belongs to a user
so let me quickly set this up in
this example
which is a blank laravel app
so let's do this quickly
so let's make a
post
make model sorry
it's making migration
okay
so let's just copy and paste stuff
so the user has many posts
so let's go to user
as many posts
a post
let's go to post here
and let's just do a belongs to
relationship and like i said we won't do
comments
here it's the same thing same
relationship between
posts and comments but
we'll just keep it simple
okay and let's just steal the
migration so it's create posts
table yep so let me just grab all of
this
and should be a great posts
there we go
okay so that should
do it
and let me just set up my environment
file
i haven't created already so root
root oh sorry it's a
graphql
variable
example
root
okay let's
migrate
and hope everything works
and it does cool
and let me just quickly
whip up some
seed data i'm going to manually in the
database
so let's make a few users
and let's make a few posts
okay so i have
two posts here two for andre and two for
john
okay so now if you take a look at
the original package so let me just
close these
okay so remember on in the first video
of the original package we spent most of
our time in this schema.graphql file
so there are
three things or two things depending on
how you want to look at it
that we have to do here so the first
thing we should do is define the types
and these types are just the models and
they have the same fields on the models
and this is how they are defined and in
the lighthouse package they conform to
the graphql specification
so all of this is the graphql
specification
but it does have some differences in
that it uses directives
to get things accomplished
in this graphql
package
graphql level package i mean
it is the same thing but everything is
in php so there's more code to write
so let's go ahead and start doing that
so let's go into the docs
and let's take a look here
say create a query
there's no dedicated documentation
page like lighthouse has
everything is in
the readme here so
so it says first you have to create a
type
and that's what we want to do so again
we want to mimic we'll start with the
user
this
okay so
you have to make a new file
in this folder app graphql type
just makes bigger
and then we have to define everything
in php like i said so everything
here we have to define it in php
okay so let's do that uh i kind of wish
this package had
a cli tool to scaffold everything out
so
that's one improvement i think
they can improve on
maybe if i have time i'll
look at
putting in a pr okay so
where does it go it goes into
app graphql type and it's called user
type
so app
new folder
graph ql
and type
let's make it a folder
type
okay
and new new file so user type so each
type is
separated into their own file
whereas in this package everything is in
here
you can actually separate them in
different files but in general
everything is in this schema.graphql
file so that's one difference
let's just paste that in
sorry i have to open php
and let's paste that in
okay let's take a look at this from the
top
all right any other errors here okay
looks good
okay so all your imports
and
the attributes
and just specifying the model
a name and a description this is fine
and this public function fields returns
an array of fields so this is the
equivalent
of
this
these are the fields
and
see within each field they have a type
and that corresponds to this
so this field has this type
and this exclamation mark means it's
required so to do required we have to
use this non-null function
so let's go ahead and do this
so we don't need this alias
because the id is
just id in the database
so we have email which is a string
so again
that is this
and it's not it's required here so
should be required but
we can add that in if we like
let's add it in
type
string
okay
and there is no name here for some
reason so let's add in name
and let's put it above email
so
let's say
name
name is required too right
yeah same so same thing
name string and description is the name
of
the user
and let's remove this is me this has to
do with authentication which we won't
look at in this video
okay so this is just
a resolver method so if you want to
return something different from what the
actual value of the field is
then you can define a resolver like this
in this format and
it will resolve it here so we're not
going to do that but it's nice to have
that option
okay so let me save this we have the
type defined
and the next thing we did in this
lighthouse package was
define the queries so we'll define the
post
in a second let's just define the
queries first
and we'll also look at the relationship
in a second
so
here we have to define all the queries
available
to the
consumer
and the most basic one is just returning
all users
so let's see how to do that
so back into the docs
so we have the type defined
and we also have
we have to add the type to the config
graphql which is already there by
default i believe so config
graphql
and there's a section for types here
somewhere
so here's a section for queries
and there's a section for types
it's actually not defined so let's go
ahead and do that so they have these
examples here
so we don't have this so i'm going to
comment this up
and same
with well when we get to queries and
mutations i'll show you that but
these don't exist so we have to remove
those okay so to define the types we
just have to
let me just grab this
and it is a user type
and that lives in
app
graphql
type
user type
class
okay
so our type is now defined
and now we can make a query
okay
so yeah it says you can use the facade
we won't be using that
okay so now
we can define the query
so let me just grab this again i kind of
wish they had
a cli generator
and this goes into app graphql query and
it's called users query
so let's do that
app graphql query
let's make a new folder
query
and
new file called
user's query
i think
that was called users query okay
let's paste this in
and let's take a look
we have
so this is just the name of the query
and this type
let's go back to our lighthouse one
so yeah this is the name so users
and
this type is what it returns
so in this case in lighthouse we want to
return a list
of users
and this is what this is saying
so list of
users
so again it's the same thing it's just
in php format
and this arguments function
sort of specifies arguments
which can be confusing because
this query can list all users but it can
also filter them down to
using an id and email
and in this implementation
we have them separate so we have one for
all users and then we have one where you
can find by an id but this one allows
you to do both
i'll show you in a second
so after that this looks fine
this is the resolver so this is where it
gets the eloquent query and retrieves
the users so in lighthouse
we
just used the all directive or the find
directive
and you can also use custom resolvers if
you want to do it that way but here
it it's more of the custom resolvers
approach where you've got to specify the
query yourself
so this is just checking if there are
arguments again i kind of think it's
better to separate it out
and then if there are arguments then
you just find them
using this eloquent query but there
isn't then you just return everything
so let's go ahead and see
if this works
i think we have to define it first in
the config so yeah right here
so we have to
specify that
this is one of the queries
so let's go into
our config again let's go up here
and again these don't exist so let me
just copy them out same with the
mutation which we'll look at in a second
and let's just paste that in
so it's exposing a user's query here and
this is where it lives and all the logic
for it
let me put a comma there
okay
so now finally if we go into our graphql
client
and what is called
graphql variable example dot test so
this is the original url i was playing
with
graphql
laravel
example.test
and let me just erase this
so this is
oh yeah so sorry that shouldn't have
brackets
okay so this should work
and it does cool
so it's returning all the users in our
database
so let me show you the arguments
so like i said it does take arguments
and they are optional
which
uh should be separate but let me just
show you that it works
and they take two arguments and i think
the id takes precedence
again this should be a separate
query but let me just show you so if i
search for id
and they defined it as a string should
be an int
but let's
say one
and then it should just return andre
there we go
okay let's quickly take a look at
relationships
because that doesn't work yet so
essentially we'd like to be able to grab
the posts from the user
and then list that out as well
so let's do that so the first thing we
have to do is
define a post type so let's go ahead and
do that
so i'm going to do a new file
post
type
php and i already have it
copied in my clipboard and it's going to
paste it in
so it's basically the same thing as the
user type just specified
for the fields of a post
so posts models post
so a post has an id
a title and content
and here's the relation which we didn't
take a look at in the user which we'll
do in a second but
we just have to specify the type so
graphql type user
and they can see find it from the config
and it's just this one that we have
already
and here's a description for it
and we don't need any custom resolvers
or anything like that
so save that and let's define the
relationship here too so i'm going to
grab this
for the user
i mean for the post in the user
so right here paste that in
and the relation is
posts
so a user has many posts
the type is
a list of posts
so we have to type
list
of
graphql
type
and type post
okay
and let me just say
a list of posts written
by the user
okay and i think i have to just import
the graphql here
and
i think it's just
graphql
and i think i have that in here already
sorry in the post type i mean
and i
do have it cool
and yeah i think that's it now we have
to specify the post
and oh we have to do the post query as
well
so let me just type that paste that in
as
well let's make a new file here called
posts query
posts query dot php
and i'm pasting it in but again it's
basically the same thing as the users
query that we did already
so it is
a
list of posts
and again there's an optional argument
which i think should be separate
and to resolve it you just have to post
all which is the one we're interested in
but if you want to pass in an id you can
do that as well
and now we just go into our config
and let's add those
so posts
and posts query
and add the type
the type is down here
post
poster type
and yes let's test this out
save last refresh
okay let's try
posts
and it's just
let's say
title
okay so it looks like it does work
content yep
okay so there is id1 if you want
everything just remove this
and there are all the posts cool
so let's try the relationship
so we want the for posts we want the
user associated with it it looks like it
works
and we want the
username and
email
so there we go so this post
was written by andre this one too this
one's written by john
and john let's take a look at
the other way
so let me just comment this out
query
users
id name but we also want
the post
and then we want the title
and that seems to work too cool
okay now let's quickly look at mutations
so let's go back into the documentation
and let's take a look at this mutation
and it's almost the same as a query
except it's a mutation so let's go ahead
and
copy this and this one is updating the
password but we'll make one for creating
a user
so let's copy that
and this goes into
app graphql mutation
so let's go to that
app graphql new folder
mutation
and what's it called
okay we have to make our own say create
user mutation
so
file
create user mutation
dot php
space the same and let's make changes
create user mutation
create
user
so the type let's go back to our
lighthouse example
so here's a create user
the type is just the thing it returns so
in our case we want to return the
created user
so that's what we're doing here
and the arguments
are the things we need to create a user
so here we have a name email and
password
so we don't need this id
but we need
name and email and i'm just going to
paste them in
to save some time
and it's basically the same thing
just we need a name and email and they
are of type string
and then in the resolve function is
where it happens
so
this is for updating the password we
don't want to do that
we want to user
create
and then we want
a name
and that's coming from
args
name
so this is what the user is specifying
in the graphql query
we want an email
and we want a password
but we want to make sure that the
password is hashed
so we do bcrypt
okay let's see if this works
and
we have to specify this in the
graphql file
so there is a section here for mutations
let me just copy this
let's paste it in
it's called
create user
and app graphql
mutation
create user
mutation
and i think that is it let's see if this
works
so let me just do it here so it is a
mutation okay
let's see if it appears
user
and then see if yeah there you go name
email and password so let's try this out
tony stark
email
tony avengers.com
and
password
is iron man
and let's return
the
id and the name
okay so hopefully this works
there we go
it created a new user
and if we just
uncomment this you should see that in
the list of users
so let me just change this to users
and let's get to names
there we go cool
so there you have it guys we've taken a
look at this graphql level package so
you can build out your graphql server
again it is a similar package to the
lighthouse package but takes a different
approach and makes use of php more
so i think they're both great it's just
a matter of preference so you try both
out and see which one you like better
i'd like to show you how you can do
authentication with graphql
we'll be looking at doing this with the
lighthouse package and laravel passport
now i'm going to be assuming that you
understand the basics of token-based
authentication with passport
if you don't make sure to watch my
videos on this which i will link to
below
there's two videos so there's one for
the back end where we set up passport
and get auth tokens returned to us upon
receiving the correct credentials
and the other one is the front end where
we take that token send it to the server
and
are able to log in
so we'll do the same here where we'll
first set up the back end with passport
and get an auth token returned to us
upon successful login
then in the next video we'll see how we
can take that token
and send it through for subsequent
requests
so let's first install passport and see
how to do this traditionally with rest
and then we'll try to mimic that with
graphql
so i'm going to be starting from the
project we built in the first video
so if you watch that video you know we
built a very basic blog implementation
where we have
users posts and comments
and a user has many posts a post has
many comments
and we set up our types here
in our graphql schema
and we also set up our queries and we
have one mutation here
so yeah
as a refresher here's a
a query we can run
there it is
so yeah i started using graphical more
if you watch the other videos i was
using graphql playground
and i've just encountered more bugs than
i do with graphical so i kind of
switched over
just kind of wish they had a dark mode
okay so let's install passport first so
if you already know how to use passport
you can feel free to skip this but i'm
gonna do it from scratch
really quickly so composer require it
that is the incorrect
repo sorry
it's a lighthouse
tutorial
this one
okay that's done what's next
next is to
migrate
okay
next is to page hprs in passport install
and this will install our clients and
we're interested in the password grant
client
so we are interested in this one so let
me just copy this
and now it says
and has api tokens to your user class
so let's do that
user
has api tokens
and let's import that
okay
next
call passport routes in your
auth service provider
auth service provider
passport routes
so i'm going to do that but i'm just
going to specify that i just want the
routes for
password grant
so passport
routes and we'll just patch pass in a
closure
function
router
and we just want something like this
router
for access
tokens
okay
make sure to import passport
and in config auth
change
the api to passport
config
off
change the api to passport
okay
i think that's it
so yeah i think that's it
so to use this again this is just the
traditional way let's do php artisan
route list
list
unexpected
service provider sorry
forgot a semicolon
okay so let's do that again
really
all right let's try
key generate
okay so there's our route list
and at the endpoint we're interested in
to log in is this oauth token
so
i'm just going to use my traditional
rest client
actually let me just
show you
um
where's the
password
grant
so here we just have to pass in again to
oauth token it's a post request
pass in all these fields
and then if it's correct then we should
get a token back
so let's go ahead and go into my risk
client and try this out
i'm going to make a new request
it's going to be called passport
login
it's going to be a post request
and let's set the header accept
application json
okay
and then set the url http
lighthouse tutorial.test
token
okay let's see if we get a response
okay let me do cool that's just because
we didn't pass in this information
which we will do so here so we'll just
pass in a
multi-part form
and it's passing everything i said here
so
grant type
is password
id
is what i copied i still have it copied
see
i don't
let me check here
okay so the id is two and the secret is
this
two
and it's
client secret i think is the next one
client secret yep
paste that in what's next
and now it's just the username and the
password
so any users in our database and i think
we have a whole bunch
let me just
user name
and password
and we don't need the
scope
okay so let's go into our database i
think i have some here
so yeah there's a whole bunch here we'll
just pick one and i think the default
password is
uh secret so i'll pick
javon
let's copy that
and let's try an incorrect password
first
and see if we get a proper response and
we do valid credentials but if it's
correct
this should return a token
and it does cool
so in our front end we would store this
in local storage or cookies
and then we would make subsequent
requests with this token and that should
authenticate us
so let me show you what i mean actually
um so if you make another request
let me just copy this
it's a get request
subsequent
request
paste that in
but if we make a request to check out
routes api
sorry let me just remove this
routes
api and this
endpoint is beha behind api slash api
slash user and it's behind this
middleware
and it's just returning the logged in
users details
so let's do that
so slash api
slash user so there's no token being
passed in yet so this should be an error
i might have to pass an application json
yeah i do
um
accept
application
json
okay
but if we pass in that token so the
header would be
authorization
and value is bearer and then the token
that's not the token
token is here
then this should return
that user's details
there we
go so yeah that's the traditional way of
doing it in rest and now let's do it in
graphql
so the creator of lighthouse actually
has a video on how to do this
which i followed
i will link it in the description if
you're curious
so i did everything manually like he
showed in the video and i actually had
it working
but then i came across someone who wrote
a package to make it even easier to do
everything
so we'll take a look at using that
instead
so this is the package here
it's called lighthouse graphql passport
auth
and
let's go ahead and use this
so let's just compose or require it
okay
next is to add these into your env file
so let's do that
just put it down here
and the client is two and the secret
is in our rest client
so it's just
this token
sorry not this token
let's token
okay
is that right that's the entire one yeah
okay
and
that is basically it this this exposes
some graphql mutations and queries
just like how we would do in rest so let
me show you what i mean
so
you can publish the config if you want
if you want to override the defaults
and here's what's inside the config but
the defaults are fine
so it exposes these new mutations so log
in refreshing token
logging out
forgot password and update forgot
password
and up here are the types for them the
types are required
so an input is a new graphql type i just
learned about using this package
so an input just sort of groups together
inputs that you need so for example this
login input
just groups together the username and
the password and it's just sort of a
cleaner way of passing in inputs into
your mutations
so i'll show you what i mean when i do
it
so the login
is of type
login input so it requires
a username and password and it returns
an auth payload so it's going to return
this stuff
which is exactly what's returned in
here
and this is the custom resolver with all
the code
so let's go ahead and try to log in and
see if we can get an access token
so let's go into graphical
and let's comment this up
and let's make a new mutation
mutation okay
and it's called login
i might have to reload this
oh i reset the size sorry
does that happen every time i reload
oh man that sucks sorry about that okay
so um
login yes login
and it is of type
login input
so yeah that input type i was talking
about
you're probably used to doing it like
this so you have to pass in
a username
and then like this
whatever
and then you pass in
a password
um so this is basically the same thing
it just groups them together and makes
it a little bit cleaner so
let me just
copy this
but now instead of passing in separate
fields you just pass in one as json so
it'd be data
and then you have to pass in json here
and you can put it it's online if you
like
the username
is
let's just give it an incorrect username
first see if we get an error
and password
and the autocomplete still works that's
good
and we still want to return some stuff
back
so
we're just interested in the access
token so let's just get that
and
yeah there we go we get this message the
user credentials were incorrect
so let's go ahead and again let's get
something from the database
let's get someone else this time let's
get
emmanuel
and paste it in here
and the password is secret and let's see
if we get that token back
and there we go there's that token
so same thing as in the rest
but now we have this token so i'm going
to copy this
and just like how i showed you for
subsequent requests in here we had this
route here we can hit
we can do something similar in graphql
so i'm going to go into my schema file
so schema graphql
and i'm going to make a new query here
called me
and this is going to be similar to this
like i said
this right here where it just returns
the
authenticated user's details
so as you can see here there is an auth
api middleware so we have to
do that here too
so it returns a user
and we're going to use the middleware
directive
and we're going to check that it
is an auth api middleware
and then we're going to also use the
auth directive which basically does
this this returns a user
but this is going to check for the
header
so it has to make sure that that token
is passed in through the header
so we can do that in our graphql client
which i'll show you here
so let me copy this again just in case
okay
so
i'm gonna
comment this out i'm gonna refresh
and make it bigger
and then i'm gonna
do that me query we just did
before passing in the headers just to
see if it works
so there it is me
and let's just say
the name and the email
see if we get anything we shouldn't get
anything because we didn't pass in the
token
okay so we're getting the http response
we want the json response so to pass the
header in this program we just go up
here edit http headers
and let's first add the
accepts
is accept i think it's accept
let's see yeah accept application json
just grab this
and then
so now this should
okay so that disappeared
where'd it go
yeah that's another bug with this
program sometimes it
when i'm in that header thing and then i
escape out sometimes the query
disappears
so let's write that again
me
name
and email
so now this should result in a json
response
so there we go on authenticated
so let's do one more let's send in that
authorization header
and the values bearer
and token oh
let's go up here
it's this
one and save
hopefully it doesn't get rid of my query
okay it's still there
but now this should work and it should
return this user's details
and there we go
so we've successfully mimicked what we
did in rest but now we're using graphql
okay let me show you the rest of the
auth endpoints here
so let's log
out
and a logout response is
returns a logout response
logout returns logout response and it's
just a status and a message okay so
let's do
that so let me
comment this out
it's just a bug it won't disappear
that sucks let me refresh it
okay
uh so log out so that is a mutation
let me put it here
mutation
log out
and what does that expect just a message
so i'm passing in the token obviously
you have to be logged in to be able to
log out so this should log the user out
okay
so this user with this token is no
longer logged in
so the token is invalidated so this
should no longer work
so i uncomment this this should not work
anymore
okay cool
and let's go ahead and log in again so
i'm gonna do this
i'm gonna uncomment this
actually no let's not log in again
because these next ones
i'm not going to refresh token but i'll
do these two
okay so forgot password
just requires an email so we'll do this
person over here
the same person
okay
so
mutation
forgot password
and was this
oh no that requires an email right
yes
so data
email
and it returns a message
and the email is this person
so before i do this let me set my email
driver to log
just so we can see it
so where's my email
sorry it should be mail
yep so let's change it to log
okay so let's try that this should work
hopefully
and we should see the email in the log
okay so this
it's saying this error because we have
to
set up the
auth scaffolding so php artisan
route
sorry
make
off okay
let's try that again
there we go we have emailed you your
password reset link
let's look for this in the darebell.log
should be this one
scroll all the way down and there it is
right there cool
and let's take a look at the last one
where we can actually update our
password
so update forgotten password
and we need all of these fields okay
and then after that we'll log in again
with that new updated password
okay so
am i doing
update forgotten password
just comment this out
let's do another mutation
update forgotten password
that is type data
and then
we need all of this stuff
so the email is
okay
the
what's next
token we can see that in
here
so it should be this
okay next is
the new password sorry
password
and it's a secret
to
and the next one is password
confirmation
secret
to
and i think this requires something
just a message again yep
and hopefully this works give it a try
there we go your password has been reset
so now
if we log in again
up here
this should not work because secret 2 is
now the new password
so let's see what we get
awesome incorrect but if we do this
and there we go cool
so there you have it guys we've managed
to use this package to recreate the
functionality of passport and everything
needed for authentication in graphql
so you might be wondering where a
register is we actually did that already
registering is just creating a new user
and we actually already have that
from the first video just creating a new
user right here
so in the next video we'll take a look
at how to use this token in the front
end using view and view apollo
i'd like to show you how you can get
authentication working in graphql with
view apollo
so if you haven't checked out the last
video we set up the server to work with
laravel passport and lighthouse and now
i'd like to see if we can get to use
view on the front end to do
authentication
so we'll build a very basic auth system
where we can log in and upon logging in
i want to show that logged in users
details so here's a very basic login
form
and i'm going to log in with an email
here
and i'm going to put in the wrong
password then we'll get this alert here
and then if i put in the right password
it will redirect
to a protected view
with that logged in user's details
and we can also log out here
cool
so yeah let's build this from scratch
using view apollo
okay so i have a view cli 3 application
scaffolded out here and the only thing
i've done is view add apollo to install
apollo
so yeah like in the last video if you
saw
we can log in using this mutation
and we get a token back
and then with this token we can call
this me query and get the user's details
back but we have to pass in this token
through the header so the question is
how do we pass it into the header
so in traditional rest if you're using
axios
you can set headers on axios so let me
just open up some code here which
is from my to do series
and let me just look for axios here
right here so you can see i'm just
setting the headers here
and i'm setting the authorization token
authorization header to bearer plus the
token which is stored in view x
so in view apollo
let me just show you something here
so there's a config file called view
apollo here in source
and you can see an auth token right here
right here
so let's search this off
token
it's called token name actually
so
okay i don't know why i did that but
what i'm trying to say is if this token
is set in your local storage then it's
going to pass that with any graphql
query or mutation that you do
and there's actually helpers here
that you can call after you log in
which sets the local storage item here
so as you can see it sets
the local
storage i think it's called apollo token
that's what i was trying to show you
earlier
it's called
the key in local storage is called
apollo token
and you have to call these methods to
create it
so on login to create it and on logout
to destroy it
so let me prove that to you
so to do that let me just put
a query in graphql query in the
hello world component
so i'm going to use this hello world
component
and i'm just going to make
some data here
okay let's return
and i'm gonna do that me query and
set it to null initially
and then i'm gonna make an apollo key
here
and me is going to be that graphql query
so
um i have to import this actually import
gql from graphql
tag
okay so now i can just do the query here
with backticks
i'm just going to do
query
and it's going to do this basically
where is it
this so me name email
me
name
email
and let's throw the id in there too
so right now the
local storage item is not set so this
should result in an error
see what we get here
so let me open up view
or console i mean
okay so yeah we do get an error failed
to fetch cool
so yeah just ignore the websocket there
so let's go ahead and log in
um
so i'm going to log in using
this mutation
just to get a valid token
okay so there's that token
and i'm going to manually
set the apollo token
just in the console here so local
storage
dot set
and the
key is called apollo token like in the
config
and i'm gonna just paste in the token
here
sorry
it's set item
okay so now if i look in my application
let me just make this bigger
local storage
and for this domain there it is right
there apollo token and
that key so now this should work
so if i refresh this
i still get failed to fetch
see if it's in here
hello world
it's undefined
oh yes sorry i forgot to set the
endpoint in the config
um so yeah i should do that before
so go view go to the apollo
i'm actually going to set the web
sockets to null to
remove that annoying error
set this to null
okay
and let's set to the end point here
right here
so what was the endpoint again it was
this
set that
okay
and now this should work
okay let me remove the
key first just to show you that it
shouldn't work when it's not there and
then we'll read it
so let me just
delete token okay
and this should not work
okay internal server error that's
correct
and let me re-add this
and now this should work
okay
let's check view
let's check hello world
check our data
and there i am me or not me but the
logged in user
so that should show you if the token is
set then it will send it for any graphql
requests
okay so with that knowledge let's get
basic logging in working
like i showed at the beginning of this
video
so i'm not going to do any state
management and i'm not going to do view
x
to manage state here
but you definitely need to do that for
any bigger application
i just want to mention that there's also
an alternate way to handle state in
graphql using something called apollo
link state
the idea is to use a graphql cache to
manage state and bypass view x entirely
i'm still in the process of learning it
so if i do i will make a separate video
for that
okay so let me quickly make
two new routes and two new pages
so
in pages and views i'm going to make a
login
view
let's just say template
login goes here
and let's make a login route so i'm just
going to copy this
and it's going to be
login
and this is going to be login
okay and i think an app that's where the
yeah the router link goes so make a new
one
say login
login
okay does this work
all right put a pipe here
and okay
and let me just paste in some code
for the login just to save some time
i'm going to paste this in and there's
already some view code in here which
i'll go over
this is the method that's called when we
submit the form
and there's a v model on the username
and the password so let's set up the
script
so we need a username and password
username empty
password
empty
and we need a methods section
so methods
and one called login
okay
and i'm also going to paste in some just
a bit of css so it's not super ugly
okay let's see how this looks
okay that's
decent and i'm going to make one more
route here for the protected
area where the login user
the logged in user's
information gets displayed
so
let's say protected
template
protected actually it's making an h2
users info
and it's going to the router add that as
well
so i'm not going to make use of guards
here
but you definitely should
what i mean by that is
i can just manually manually go to this
route and it will show up it won't show
the
logged in users details if you're not
logged in but you can still show the
route and you should use guards to
prevent the user from doing that
so yeah check out my video
and my video on just doing it in rest
and it's the same thing
it's protected
okay
so i'm not going to put it in the menu
because
i don't want that to show but we can
actually just go here
so yeah that's what i mean if you had
cards in place you wouldn't be able to
go here if you're not logged in
okay and we'll put the login route in a
second after i finish logging in
and i'm not gonna do any validation here
as i'm just giving you a very basic
example
okay so
here we want to perform the login
mutation
here
and
if it's successful
we want to call that on login helper
which sets the
token in our local storage
let me actually remove this because it's
already here i'm going to delete that
okay
so if we go into here we can see how to
do mutations and i'm just going to copy
this
let me just grab everything
this is the entire methods key
and i'm going into
login
okay so this is all of methods
okay let's indent this
and change it to login
and i don't want any of this
okay
i also need
this gql
so import
gql from
graphql tag
okay
don't need any of this
okay
so the mutation we need is this one
so let me just grab this actually
and paste it in
and we can indent this
and let's make some changes here
so i am going to
accept some data
and it is of type login input it's
required
and
this i'm going to cut out
and the data goes here
and i want to return the access token
and the variables
is where i'm going to paste
what i just cut
and this should come from our state
which is bound to v model so it should
update as the user updates
and that should work
so let's see if this works so let's just
see if we get the token in our console
so that looked like it worked
the work
don't need this
okay so that worked
let's test this out
here
refresh
so i'm going to use the same user here
let's try an error case first i'm going
to type in gibberish
okay so it's an
error
is that the right error
we'll see let's type in the right
password
okay so i'm missing something here
so yeah i am missing another
yeah so this should be
another key so data is this
like this
okay
let's give that another try
so wrong password
okay now we're getting the correct user
error
user credentials were incorrect
and correct password we should get some
data here
there we go this should include the
token
where is it there it is right there
so now we just have to set
or call the helper the on login helper
i've been talking about in here
in view apollo
on login
right here
so let's go ahead and do that
so
back to here we have to import it let's
import it
import
on login
from
up one
view
apollo okay
and now we can just use that or just
called it when it's successful
so let me just call it right here
so on login
and what parameters does need it needs
the apollo client and the token
so
the client is just this
apollo
provider
default client
and the token is data.data.login.access
token if you remember
here so data data login access token
or you can destructure it if you like
i'll just leave it
and i also want it to go to that
protected route so this
router
push
protected
and let's try this again and now the
local storage key should be set
so
let's refresh
okay
secret
and then
let's check the application so it's not
in here it should be in here
there we go let's set it right there
and we'll work on
showing the user's info in here in a
second
i just want to work on logout
so we can destroy this token
okay so back to our code
let's go to app view
and we can make a new link here
it's not a router link it's just going
to be a normal link
because there's no view associated with
it
so
i'm going to click that prevent and
we'll call a logout function
and say log out
let's make a pipe here too
and down here
script
let's make a new method
log out
and we're just going to do the same
thing we did in here
i'm going to import on log out instead
of on log in
there on log
out
and we are going to
just call it on logout
and the only parameter it takes is the
apollo provider
apollo provider
default client
and i want to push to the home page
and all this is going to do like i said
is just destroy that token in our local
storage
so let's give that a try
oh sorry this
is in the same directory
okay
so i am logged in right now but if i hit
log out this should be deleted and it
should redirect
awesome
okay now let's work on that protected
page
so yeah all we have to do is just call
that me query and since the
token is set that should work out
so we already did that in the hello
world so let's just copy that
so i'm just going to copy
all of this
and then
i'm going to
comment it out here because we're not
using it
and protected
let's just do it in here
okay
let's just import
this
okay
let's see if
this works
and let me just output it
here
let's do
media id
name
email
and we only want to output that if it's
set so i'll just do v if me
and we're going to need a root div here
okay
see if this works
so let's log in
and
okay i don't have it in there anymore
where's my
email there it is
that's not it
okay
secret
so there we go
you can see it got set in here and we
are redirected to the correct page
with this user's information
so there you have it guys we managed to
build out the authentication on the
front end using the token we got from
the server
and using vue apollo and its helpers
please like
comment and subscribe if you haven't
already done so
thanks for watching guys see you in the
next one
okay thanks bye
[Music]
you